[Musique]
Branco, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview.
On vous reçoit dans le cadre de votre
dernier ouvrage qui s'appelle
Crépuscule, la version préfacée par
Denis Robert, journaliste
d'investigation.
Comment ça va ? Très bien.
C'est euh c'est un moment spécial pour
moi parce que on a
ce texte que qui avait été mis en ligne
en en novembre dernier qui est une
enquête sur la Macronie et ses liens
avec l'oligarchie avec certaines des
personnes les plus puissantes du pays
voire du monde. Xavignel, Bernard
Arnaud, première fortune mondiale 4e
fortune mondiale pardon, première
fortune française
euh leur sbir leur second couteau, leurs
hommes de main. Et c'est un travail qui
qui pouvait pas être édité en France en
fait parce qu'il il révélait trop de
liens de compromission entre le milieu
de l'édition, le milieu politique, le
milieu médiatique et les puissances
économiques qui contrôlent en fait une
grande partie de ces médias,
éditeur et cetera et euh et le droit tel
qu'il existe en France et l'écosystème
tel qu'il est en France aujourd'hui
empêchait euh sa publication sous une
forme classique. Et euh et je me suis
pris beaucoup de murs en fait. Euh et à
un moment, j'ai décidé de le mettre en
ligne et je trouve qu'il y a quelque
chose de d'intéressant qui s'est passé
dans ce pays qui est le mouvement des
gilets jaunes et euh et qui a donné un
écho hallucinant au texte. Il y a eu sur
le seul lien que j'avais mis, mais il y
a eu énormément de versions pirates,
plus de 750000 téléchargements
et et la chose a commencé à circuler.
Alors, on a commencé à en parler en
Norvège, en Inde, j'ai fait la matinale
de la première radio belge, entouré
l'Espagne, la France et et pas un mot en
France. un mois en France pendant des
semaines. Pourtant avec des révélations
euh de première importance, par exemple,
comment Édouard Philippe avait fait
recruter sa femme à Science Poau euh
alors qu'il venait d'attribuer des des
subventions euh en tant qu'adjoint au
maire du Havre à ScienceP à un poste où
elle n'avait pas les qualifications
requises évidemment dans une affaire de
euh de conflit d'intérêt voir de
corruption très claire des éléments
factuels he prouvés qui sont qui sont
établis. On est en direct donc pas de
diffamation.
C'est très très sourcé en fait. Et c'est
là la force du du texte. Je pense c'est
que tout est il y a tout une partie qui
est enquêtée et il y a surtout il y a
toute une partie qui vient de de mon
expérience au sein de ces espaces.
C'est-à-dire que
Est-ce que Est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succintement ?
Oui. Alors, j'ai fait moi les toutes les
grandes écoles qu'il faut faire. Science
P, normal sup. J'ai fait une thèse en
droit, j'ai fait des masters, Robbon et
cetera et j'avais vocation à intégrer
ces espaces là. En gros, j'étais reçu
par Xaviniel en jevier 2014 pour
déjeuner comme il le fait avec tous les
prétendants
futurs ou présents au haut direction de
ce pays, ceux qui sont sélectionnés,
cooptés et cetera. Euh j'ai travaillé
avec OK d'ors à Cour internationale et
cetera et euh et j'ai appris en fait à
partir de là à à comprendre en fait ces
espaces de pouvoir, comment ils se
nourrissaient.
J'ai grandi aussi dans le 5e et 6e
arrondissement parisien même si je suis
je suis n en Espagne. Mais donc j'ai
commencé à aussi à découvrir la
socialité donc pas seulement comme
quelqu'un qui travaillait pour eux mais
qui aussi les les fréquentait voyait
comment ils fonctionnait.
J'ai découvert tout un système de
compromission d'intérêt qui qui
desservait en fait le la cause commune,
le le bien commun et et j'ai commencé à
m'y intéresser à chaque fois plus en
tant que journaliste, en tant
qu'enquêteur, en tant que militant. Donc
j'ai j'ai commencé à écrire dans le
monde diplomatique dans un certain
nombre de choses et j'ai commencé à
décrypter en fait ces rouages dans
lesquels on avait essayé de me de
m'infiltrer. Il y a une scène
extraordinaire que je raconte pas dans
le livre mais j'avais travaillé avec
Richard Descoin qui était quelqu'un qui
est le direct était le directeur de
ScienceP un directeur mythique de
ScienceP Paris parce que pendant 20 ans,
il a essayé de faire de l'ouverture
sociale et cetera mais surtout un homme
de pouvoir très important. Il m'avait
recruté quand j'avais quand j'avais 18
ans quand j'étais en première année de
sciences. On s'était croisé, il avait il
avait aimé un certain nombre de choses
que j'avais fait et j'avais refus
j'avais arrêté de travailler pour lui au
moment où il avait accepté la mission
Sarkozi sur les lycées qui en fait
devait l'amener à devenir ministre
d'éducation. Lui qui était censé être un
homme de gauche qui tout d'un coup se se
laissait absorber par le système. Grande
crise, il comprenait pas pourquoi je
voulais pas le suivre pour
éventuellement devenir après son
conseiller ministériel et cetera. Moi,
je considérais qu'il y avait une
question éthique fondamentale qui est ne
serait-ce que du respect de l'électorat,
mais enfin un moment de dire on peut pas
passer de l'un à l'autre sans de façon
indifférente.
Et euh et en 2011 euh donc c'est j'avais
beaucoup moins interagi avec lui. En
2011, il y a des polémiques qui
commencent à sortir sur sa gestion de
sciences pot, des rapports de la cour de
compte qui commencent à filtrer comme
quoi il aurait institué ce qui était
vrai, un système de cours. il utilisait
l'argent public pour recruter des
personnes qui allaient le servir dans sa
dans ses ambitions et en même temps qui
était censé aussi servir ces idées qui
pouvaient être intéressantes.
Et à ce moment-là, j'ai découvert un
homme complètement abattuelé. C'estàdire
que toutes les personnes qui toute cette
cours qu'il avait construit autour de
lui qui est très importante hein parce
que c'est on parle vraiment du tout
petit Paris donc des personnes qui ont
un pouvoir immense qui ont des grands
salaires qui avaient des des
appartements de fonction qui étaient
financés par l'État c'est des salaires
qui pouvaient monter jusqu'à jusqu'à je
pense qu'il gagnait sauf erreur de ma
part lui 500000 € par an financé par
l'État vous voyez quatre ou cin fois
plus qu' un président d'université et
donc il y avait beaucoup de salaires
comme comme celui-là et tout tout le
monde a disparu c'estàd qu'il s'est
retrouvé complètement seul et à ce
moment là, moi je me suis dit que cette
personne qui m'avait appris une chose,
c'est que les concours de de la
République, contrairement à ce qu'on
fait croire ne servent pas à recruter
les meilleurs mais seulement à provoquer
de la reproduction sociale. Et on se
rend compte par le fait qu'il y a 1 %
aujourd'hui de fils d'ouvriers ou
d'employés à Polytechnique ou à Normal
Supors que c'est
c'est 30 % de la population française et
que ces concours sont censés être
égalitaires et permettre à chacun
d'avoir exactement les mêmes chances de
réussir. descoins m'avait complètement
Richard des coquesin m'avait
complètement
rompu en fait cette illusion comme quoi
si j'avais réussi ces concours et que
moi-même j'avais un mérite spécial et
cetera et m'avait commencé m'avait amené
à interroger ces systèmes de
reproduction sociale et à quel point ils
étaient insupportables. Donc cette
personne m'avait apporté des choses même
si par ailleurs elle avait essayé de
m'utiliser en me faisant insérer dans
ses réseaux de pouvoir et cetera. C'est
pas le seul. J'ai rencontré beaucoup
d'hommes politiques qui ont essayé de
m'absorberisme éducatif
mais c'est une violence extraordinaire.
Je vais revenir là-dessus d'ailleurs
parce que j'ai j'ai enseigné ensuite en
banlieu et j'ai j'ai je suis allé
chercher l'autre pan, moi qui avait été
dans des dans des grands lycée entre
guillemets du centre de Paris, l'école
asacienne et cetera
et j'ai vraiment vu cette violence à la
fois du côté élites et aussi de ceux qui
en souffraient en tout bout de chaîne.
Euh tout ça sous la chappe de plomb d'un
discours républicain égalitaire
méritocratique et cetera. Mais je j'en
reviens dessus. Donc cette personne qui
qui m'avait ouvert en fait quelque part
au moins là-dessus, je me dis est-ce que
est-ce que oui en effet je laisse cette
personne en gros sombrer parce que elle
a fait peut-être quelque chose de mal et
cetera ou est-ce qu'un moment j'ai la
j'ai la dignité en fait de dire c'est
pas c'est pas dans mes intérêts mais
cette personne est seule elle m'a
apporté quelque chose elle a besoin
d'aide j'y vais donc je suis revenu vers
lui et pour quelques mois de janvier à
avril 2012 j'ai commencé à travailler
avec lui à essayer de proposer des
projets de réforme de science po qui
permettrai de le sortir de l'ornière
cette personne est morte te subitement.
Je pense que c'était le 3 avril 2012,
donc en pleine campagne présidentielle.
Moi, j'étais
je travaillais pour pendant la campagne
parce que pour faire une réforme
d'ADOPI, j'ai beaucoup milité contre
Adopi et au François Hollande avait
promis de supprimer l'ADOPI. C'était moi
qui avais réussi à lui faire dire ça
dans un discours au bis de Nantes. Il
trahirait sa promesse et et il me
m'éjecterait de la campagne au 6 mai
2012. à ce moment-là, j'étais encore
dedans et cette personne meurt. Et et
alors arrive quelque chose de très
étrange, c'est que dans les 12 heures de
sa mort euh
se met en place un réseau, en tout cas
réapparaît le réseau qu'il avait
constitué pour essayer de faire fond et
empêcher que quoi que ce soit ne
s'effondre du fait de sa mort. Et donc
j'ai vu des personnes d'un cynisme
absolu commencer à à mettre en place une
vraie stratégie de captation
d'information du pouvoir. Ils ont fermé
les bureaux, ils ont commencé à enlever
toutes les données et cetera et ils ont
essayé de m'intégrer en fait à cette à
un fonctionnement quasi mafieux qui
consistait à ce que aucune information
ne fuite, aucune information sur toutes
les compromissions que lui et toutes les
personnes autour de lui avaient mis en
place les 15 dernières années.
Et je pense que le le moment ultime euh
de cette compromission, ça a été le
moment où sa veuve Nadia Maric qui
travaillait à Sciencep, qui l'avait
recruté à Sciencep, euh il avait été
dans son jury de concours de LENA, il
avait fait LENA, euh il s'était mis
ensemble. Euh euh cette femme euh me dit
pour euh pour construire en fait par
cette solidarité de corps mais
physiquement, elle me donne rendez-vous
dans le nord de Paris, un endroit que je
connaissais pas. m'a dit il faut que tu
viennes et cetera parce qu'elle m'a
appelé quasiment juste après sa ban pour
me dire voilà il faut qu'on se voit
Richard et cetera et elle m'amène et je
en fait je me retrouve au crématorium de
de Paris et et je la vois avec quelqu'un
qui est en train de pleurer dans ses
bras et cette personne que je
connaissais vaguement dont des quoi on
m'avit beaucoup parlé s'appelle Laurent
Bigorgne. Et en fait je je décris dans
le livre comment Laurent Bigorgne a été
une des clés de l'ascension de Macron au
sein des petites élites parisiennes dans
phase de coptation avant qu'il devienne
président de la République. et je vois
pleurer et cetera. Je me demande ce que
je fais là et euh et cette femme Nadia
Marie m'amène
dans une salle et elle me montre le
corps de Richard Descour.
Et alors là, moi à un moment, j'ai un
j'avais 22 ans, enfin je je complètement
troublé par ce qui je comprends pas ce
qui est en train de se passer et je lui
dis mais euh et évidemment comme ces
fonctionnements de cours produisent des
effets assez incroyables et donc pendant
un moment il y avait eu des rumeurs
comme quoi j'avais été l'amant de
Richard Descoin qui avait en fait une
double vie. Il était par ailleurs
homosexuel et je pense très amoureux de
sa femme. Il avait l'amand de Guillaume
Pépi. Ça c'est été écrit après par la
suite le PDG de la SNCF qui était son
l'homme de sa vie et il avait donc cette
cette double vie comme ça et je pense
qu'il y a une confusion à un moment on a
cru que j'étais son am donc à un moment
je me dis mais merde elle pense que
j'étais son amant enfin et que qu'elle
m'amène là. Et en fait, j'ai compris
beaucoup plus tard que c'était pas du
tout ça. C'était que elle voulait
absolument tenir le clan qui risquait de
s'effondrer et qu' l'avait constitué par
peur que sa mort provoque ça et
s'assurer que rien ne sorte et rien ne
filtre de ce qui s'était passé. Et en
fait, il fallait en passer pour ça par
des stratégies comme ça de pénétration
dans l'espace intime qui allaient
sidérer les interlocuteurs et s'assurer
qu'il resterait là.
C'est pas votre interprétation ? Je suis
non, c'est une factualité je pense parce
que la façon dont ça s'est mis en place
ensuite l'a démontré. C'estàd que
ensuite elle me demande de faire
l'hommage au nom des étudiants à Richard
Descoins. Donc je me retrouve à l'église
Saint-Sulpis, un endroit où il y avait
toutes les élites du pays qui s'étaient
réunies devant 500 personnes tremblant,
traumatisé parce que je parle à des
personnes qui pensent que j'étais la
moindre des coins. En tout cas, c'est ce
que je pense à 22 ans, vous voyez. Enfin
moi j'avais une histoire d'amour avec
une femme depuis des années. Enfin, il y
un un événement extrêmement traumatique
et et je me rends compte en fait des
instruments qui se mettent en place avec
la proposition par la suite de
travailler avec quelqu'un qui s'appelait
David Azema qui était le responsable de
l'APE, l'Agence des participations de
l'État. Donc ceux qui gèrent en fait les
actions que l'État détient dans
entreprises parapluqu,
les grandes entreprises, les
participations d'État en fait dans
l'économie et et ainsi de suite. Et en
fait c'est ces réseaux-là, je vais les
voir se mettre en place pour se
mobiliser en fait pour défendre leur
candidat à partir de 2014. Un certain
Emmanuel Macron qui sorti de nulle part
va être propulsé par cet espace
technocratique par toutes ces personnes
qui avaient essayé de m'absorber entre
2007 et 2012 parce qu'il considérait à
tort au raison que j'étais un des plus
brillants peut-être de cet espace-là. et
que j'avais peut-être aussi la jeunesse
suffisante pour me laisser absorber sans
me rendre compte. Et en effet, quand
j'ai travaillé pendant un an pour des
coins, je comprenais pas, j'avais
accepté
heureux qu'on me fasse cette confiance
mais sans comprendre que toutes les
flatteries et cetera et tout était
instrumental, avait un objectif, c'était
de m'absorber pour me faire servir le
système un système qui n'avait qu'un
intérêt, c'était de défendre ses propres
intérêts. Ses propres intérêts et non
pas une idée et servir en fait leurs
ambitions pour avoir une place dans
l'espace social et cetera. ce qui
faisait qu'il pouvait passer de la
gauche à la droite, de la droite à
gauche dans aucune sans aucune
difficulté. Et en fait cette découverte
intime du fonctionnement de ce qui
deviendrait le en même temps d'Emmanuel
Macron de ces différents personnages
clés des coins qu'il connaissaiit depuis
2004, Laurent Bigorgne qui serait qui
est devenu entre-temps le président de
l'Institut Montigne qui est l'Institut
de lobbying du CAC 40 qui produit des
études d'Foison pour essayer de former
l'opinion publique pour les amener à des
réformes en faveur des des grandes
entreprises tout en donnant l'impression
que ils sont neutres et qui a été
mobilisé pour servir à l'élection
d'Emmanuel Macron.
toute une série d'é fonctionnaires.
Jean-Pierre Jouillet surtout qui est un
un personnage cardinal que je décris
dans le livre, je vais pas revenir en
détail sur son parcours mais qui est
extrêmement important pour comprendre
comment est-ce que quelqu'un comme
Emmanuel Macron a pu se retrouver euh à
son âge propulsé à de telles fonctions
sans être jamais confronté au suffrage
universel ni à une quelconque forme de
contrôle démocratique.
Jean-Pierre Juliet qui est marié à
Brigitte Étinger qui est l'héritière des
grandes d'une des plus grandes familles
industrielles du pays et et donc j'ai
découvert cette sorte d'espace comme ça
où on essayait on a essayé pendant
quelques années de m'intégrer dans les
gragues. Bernard Spitz qui a essayé de
me draguer qui fait partie des personnes
qui ont qui ont essayé de propulser
Macron. On m'a amené au Havre pour
l'inauguration d'une stelle euh en
l'hommage à Richard Descoins. Organisé
par qui ? par Édouard Philippe euh le le
maire du Havre à l'époque qui était donc
celui qui avait fait recruter à Science
Po sa femme en échange des subventions.
Enfin vous voyez donc c'est don contre
don en fait qui se mettait en place dans
le change
des subventions
c'est avéré ça ? Oui oui, c'est établi
et défini par Édouard Philippe lui-même
dans l'a dit dans un discours public en
fait où il assumé que c'était lui en
tant qu'adjent du maire qui avait décidé
de l'appui donné à Sciencep. Et donc
Richard Descoin peut-être avait quelque
part une idée de ce que devait être la
politique éducative du pays qui
justifiait ou pouvait justifier pour
certains le fait qu'il mette en place
tous ces réseaux de d'appui d'intérêt et
cetera afin d'arriver à ses fins et de
réussir à imposer des élites sclérosées
dans lesquelles vous parliez de génisme
social. Je pense que c'est un terme qui
est qui est violent et juste, qui vise à
empêcher euh à 90 % de la population
d'accéder à des hautes fonction, quel
que soit leur talent, parce que on veut
garder les places pour nos propres
héritiers euh enfin des classes
dominantes. Euh ce qui était pouvait se
justifier ne se justifiait plus à sa
main parce que ce tout ce réseau s'est
retrouvé sans sans idéologue en quelque
sorte et donc juste à paniquer à l'idée
de perdre sa place, la place que qui
s'était attribuée mutuellement. Donc ils
ont commencé à tourner à vide et
Emmanuel Macron en fait c'est un peu
l'archétype de ce vide, c'est-à-dire de
personnes qui cherchent à prendre place
dans la société sans aucun moment porter
une idée particulière si ce n'est celle
qui va leur permettre d'arriver au
pouvoir. Et ce que je raconte dans mon
livre, c'est comment les nombreux
interlocuteurs m'ont raconté dès le
début Emmanuel Macron rentre dans le
piège euh de la flatterie. C'est-à-dire
qu'il va croire en effet qu'il est un
génie, qu'il est quelqu'un de
particulièrement brillant comme on a
essayé de me le faire croire moi très
jeune. Euh et il va en fait ne pas se
rendre compte qu'en qu'en qu'en rentrant
dans ce système, il va devenir l'agent
des personnes qui le propulsent. Euh non
pas parce qu'il croirait dans l'absolu
du génie d'une personne et cetera, mais
parce qu'il voit bien que cette
personne-là va leur être utile pour
défendre leurs intérêts, qu'il est
suffisamment naïf et cetera. Donc ce
petit jeune qui arrive d'amien avec sa
femme qui va devenir professeur à
Franklin,
un lycée privé de la rive droite où tous
les héritiers de Paris de cette de la
bourgeoisie financière et de l'ancienne
aristocratie parisienne se regroupe pour
ne pas être dans le public, pour ne pas
être mêlé avec d'autres avec d'autres
avec des des personnes qui seraient
d'émanants, des personnes qui qui
n'apporteraient pas suffisamment en
terme de dote sociale, en terme de
capital économique symbolique ou autres
qui ne sont rien.
Des gens qui ne sont rien. Et vous allez
voir en fait tout ça s'emboîte de façon
assez assez fascinante. Cette femme va y
rencontrer les enfin il va pardon y
éduquer les enfants de Bernard Arnaud ce
qui va lui permettre de rencontrer
Bernard Arnaud ce qui va lui permettre
de présenter Bernard Arnaud à à Emmanuel
Macron.
Arnaud qui va être un des principaux
soutiens de Macron. Euh il va dîner euh
jusque une fois par semaine quand avec
euh Emmanuel Macron quand celui-ci
devient ministre de l'économie et va se
mettre en place voilà va se mettre en
branle une machine qui va amener au
pouvoir quelqu'un euh qui n'avait pas
forcément ni euh les capacités ni euh ni
l'envie fondamentale, je crois, euh sans
sans autre raison que celle de préserver
un système qui était en train de
s'effondrer parce que les candidats du
système étaient chacun les uns après les
autres en train de chuter et qu'il
fallait absolument trouver une une
solution de rechange avant que la
rupture se mette en place.
Et donc moi, je pars de cette intimité
que j'ai eu avec cet espace qui m'a été
imposée parce que j'ai jamais rien
demandé et on m'a par effet de
suggestion successive, parfois par
naïveté au début de ma part, mais en
même temps très rapidement par
compréhension de ce qui se jouait, par
attrait aussi à idée de pouvoir
travailler au ministère des affaires
étrangères à 23 ans en poste de cabinet
en plus, même s'il était caché parce que
il y a les limites de cabinets de nombre
de conseillers dans le cabinet. Et puis
après, évidemment, il y a des façons de
contourner pour trouver de la chair
fraîche qui vous servira. Euh et dans
toute une série d'autres dispositifs,
euh j'ai j'ai vu j'ai vu vraiment de
l'intérieur comment fonctionnaient ces
gens-là, socialement, intimement,
politiquement et cetera. Et et ça, je
pense que c'est très rare. Et ça, je
pense que c'est très rare parce que
c'est toujours c'est très difficile en
fait de de l'extérieur de comprendre ce
qui me s
un traite à votre cast
à une classe à laquelle j'ai jamais
appartenu mais auqu à laquelle ils ont
cru que j'appartenais
et à une caste aussi bien sûr, mais les
deux une tentative une tentative
d'élaboration de caste parce que une
caste une caste est censée avoir une
fonction dans la société. une caste dans
au sens anthropologique du terme, c'est
ça va être la casse des hermeneutres, la
casse des sorciers, la casse des qui va
en fait jouer une fonction pour la
société et qui va justifier
l'attribution de privilège particulier.
En France, il y a des castes qui ne
servent à rien, qui sont complètement
inutiles ou qui accueillent des
personnes qui sont des parasites qui
vont en fait s'appuyer sur le la labeur
que de millions de personnes qui sont
exploitées plus ou moins violemment dans
ce pays pour en tirer des bénéfices et
pour en s'appuyant sur des registres de
corruption plus ou moins actifs en tirer
en tirer voilà des revenus, une position
sociale, une un prestige et cetera. Et
et quand je me suis rendu compte à quel
point ces gens étaient évidés, à quel
point en fait il n'avaiit il n'avaiit
rien à faire de l'idée ou alors que
parce que justement il ne servait que
des intérêts et que en fait l'intérêt
c'est l'inverse de l'idée. Quand vous
pensez en terme d'intérêt, vous ne
pouvez l'idée vous permet de sublimer
l'intérêt, de contourner en fait cette
cette insuffisance et bien je me
je m'en suis naturellement détaché en
fait. Je me suis naturellement détaché
et moi qui étais rentré dans la campagne
de François Hollande que je nessimais
pas particulièrement voir loin de loi
parce que je portais une idée très forte
qui était celle de la réforme de euh de
du droit d'auteur qui était la mise en
place d'une licence globale qu'on a fini
par avoir hein parce que Netflix,
Spotify, tout ça c'est des licences
globales, sauf que c'est licence globale
privée et ça on le prévenait à l'époque.
Le seul modèle économique pour la
culture au 21e siècle c'est un accès de
type licence globale illimité sur
abonnement ou pris en charge par l'État.
Quel aurait été l'avantage de prendre en
charge par l'État ? c'est qu'on aurait
pas eu euh ce déversoir de contenu
complètement pourissant qui aujourd'hui
habite ces ces ces plateformes et on
aurait pu justement avoir une politique
culturelle active qui nous aurait permis
d'une part d'être autonome de
plateformes qui ne payent pas leurs
impôts, qui sont aux États-Unis, qui
nous imposent une vision du monde qui
n'a rien à voir avec notre culture ou en
tout cas qui nous amène à une sorte
d'acculturation complète et de défendre
notre création, de rayonner dans le pays
et cetera comme les lois langues
l'avaient fait dans les années 80.
Le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui nos nos
élites politiques n'ont pas du tout le
même niveau qu'elles ont eu jusqu'à une
certaine période. C'est dans les années
80 quand Méran arrive au pouvoir, il a
cette intuition très forte qui est de se
dire "Moi, il faut que je crée des
élites qui vont m'appuyer, qui fassent
contrepoids aux élites qui ont été
créées par la droite qui est au pouvoir
de façon ininterrompue depuis plus de 30
ans. Donc il faut que je m'appuie, j'ai
des ressorts au sein du petit Paris qui
vont me stabiliser, qui vont m'aider."
Donc c'est pour ça qu'il va mettre en
place une politique culturelle dans
laquelle il va ouvrir les robinets euh à
la fois avec la création de télévision
privée comme Canal Plus et cetera, mais
qui elles-mêmes vont financer une éque
culturelle qui va monter parce que il va
la télévision va financer massivement le
cinéma et cetera et vous allez avoir des
personnes qui vont devenir
sociologiquement de gauche. Pourquoi ?
Parce que c'est la gauche qui leur a
permis d'exister. L'argent que que leur
donne la gauche bah fait que ils vont
devenir de gauche. Mais en fait quel est
le problème quand vous avez des élites
de cet ordre là ? c'est qu'il y a une
seule question donc à laquelle ils vont
être complètement différents, c'est la
question sociale parce que justement ils
vivent des prébandes que leur donne
l'État. Donc ils ne se posent même pas
la question sociale. Ils sont protégés,
vivent dans une économie fermée dans
laquelle la régulation de l'État leur
permet d'avoir accès à des ressources.
Donc il se posent jamais la question de
savoir s'ils vont se faire évincer ou
pas. Et donc évidemment être de gauche
sans se poser la question sociale, ce
qui est le drame de la social-démocratie
en France depuis 30 ans, ça pose
question. Donc c'est qu'à un moment
votre élite c'est frite mais quand même
dans les 80 on faisait cette émergence
comme ça de toute une élite culturelle
qui va servir d'appui
à cette force politique et aux idées
qu'elle est censée porter. Et en même
temps, vous comprenez comme ça pourquoi
la la gauche mitérandienne au début très
social va probement progressivement
basculer vers quelque chose qui n'avait
plus rien à voir.
Très bien.
Voilà. Et bien nous en 2012 euh moi
quand je rentre dans campagne de France
Hollande, il n'a même pas ce cynisme
c'estàd ou ce début cet aersat de pensée
qui est de se dire bon ben il faut on a
une il y a une manne d'argent potentiel
qui est la la politique culturelle qui
est en train de naître sur internet avec
tous les fournisseurs d'accès qui font
des fortunes sans aucune raison parce
qu'ils ont accès à des à des marchés
captifs. Si on en tire une partie pour
la redistribuer qu'on recrée une
culturelle parce que la nôtre est en
train de dépérir bien peut-être que ces
personnes-là vont du coup derrière avoir
intérêt à défendre nos politiques et nos
idées. Vous voyez ce qui pourrait être
quelque chose de relativement cynique
mais en même temps qui peut faire sens
n'est même pas pensé n'est même pas
pouré parce que ces personnes là qui
arrivent au pouvoir
par inertie c'estàd que François
Hollande c'est quelqu'un qui le raconte
dans les années 80 il fait l'ENAT il
réussit le concours de l'ENAT et à
partir de là ça devient un aristocrate.
Exactement comme Emmanuel Macron sa
nouvelle aristocratie que j'ai décris
dans dans dans mon livre. C'est-à-dire
que il a une charge, il rentre dans un
grand corps, la cour des comptes où il y
a une vidéo de lui extraordinaire où il
raconte non c'est extra encore mieux, il
raconte en 83 84, il dit oui moi vous
savez moi je suis à cours des comptes
donc je gagne l'équivalent de 5 6000 €
par mois et je peux travailler 4 5
heures par semaine et je pourrais me
contenter de ça toute ma vie et ça
serait très bien sans aucune distance
par rapport à à ce qu'il dit François
Hollande et en fait François Hollande va
envoyer Jean-Pierre Jouillet et c'est
pour ça en fait ces personnages qui
reviennent et qui s'installe à
l'inspection des finances qui est encore
un corps supérieur à celui de la Cour
des comptes qui est censé être le corps
de contrôle de des finances de l'État
pour que Jean-Pierre Jouillet tisse un
réseau au sein de la haute
administration qui nourrisse la carrière
politique de François Hollande. Donc
François Hollande comme il à la cour des
comptes, il a très peu de travail, il va
pouvoir faire des campagnes politiques,
donc utiliser l'argent de l'État pour
pour se construire une carrière
politique par parétque et il va
s'appuyer sur son ami son ami génial
Jean-Pierre Juliet pour pour le nourrir.
Et donc à part
c'est pas votre lecture de la situation
ça c'est ça c'est raconté par les
protagonistes même. C'est ça qui est
extraordinaire. C'est eux-mêmes qui
racontent comment François Hollande
concède son poste dans la botte à
Jean-Pierre Juillet pour pour qu'il
prenne place, prenne pied dans l'État
pour pour le servir. Et ils vont faire
cette alliance entre la technocratie
d'État et et ce que cette sorte d'hersat
de réseau politique que François
Hollande va constituer. Et en fait, par
inertie, cette personne va devenir
président de la République. Il va
devenir président de la République parce
que et si c'est la seule façon
aujourd'hui de comprendre pourquoi il
pense encore pouvoir revenir. Pourquoi ?
Cette chose qui semble absurde à tout le
monde chez lui ne l'est pas. Il
considère qu'il a un droit à l'idée de
devenir président de la République parce
que il a eu ce parcours au sein de
l'aristocratie d'État qui fait qu'il est
prédestiné à cette position là parce que
en ayant combiné ça avec un engagement
politique, ça fait partie des quelques
élus qui peuvent mais vous voyez à quel
point tout ça n'a rien à voir avec un
rapport avec le rapport avec la
démocratie.
Enfin n'a aucun rapport avec la
démocratie. D'autant plus si vous
rajoutez, on en revient à cette question
d'éducation, que ces concours, bah pour
sélectifs qu'ils soit, sont surtout
discriminants socialement et ne servent
qu'à la reproduction du même et pas du
tout à à la à à faire émerger des
personnes qui, du fait de leur talent
auraient une capacité à gouverner
particulièrement notre pays. C'est pour
ça qu'on comprend la délicence aussi de
notre pouvoir politique aujourd'hui qui
n'est ni orienté idéologiquement parce
que c'est pas des personnes qui ont un
militantisme, un parcours vraiment qui
ont vécu dans leur chair quelque chose
qui fait qu'ils se sont engagés
politiquement, ni une compétence
particulière parce que cette illusion de
compétence àquelle on a voulu nous faire
croire à propos d'Emmanuel Macron
évidemment complètement fabriqué ne
servait qu'à une chose ne servait qu'à
imposer
cette personnage dans l'espace public.
qu'il fallait bien justifier le fait que
cette personne émerge du jour lendemain.
On a commencé à dire que qu'il avait eu
un trisè, je finis là-dessus, qu'il
avait eu un un ce qui m'a fait le plus
rire dans cette opération de propagande
qu'il y a eu à partir de5 avec l'appui
de la garder Niel Arnaud et cetera,
c'est quand
c'est quand on a commencé à dire "Mais
non mais c'était un grand philosophe
parce qu'il avait été assistant de
Ricker et cetera." Mais après ils
étaient tellement à cours d'argument
qu'à un moment ils ont dit ils ont parlé
du troisème prix qu'il avait eu de piano
au concours municipal d'Amir et c'était
devenu en fait la preuve que cet homme
était par ailleurs un pianiste émérite
et cetera. C'est comme il n'y avait
aucun argument démocratique politique de
parcours de vie parce que cette personne
avait dans sa vie on essayait de le
présenter comme le mozard à finance tout
ça parce qu'il était il avait pillé les
réseaux que l'État lui avait donné quand
était rentré à l'inspection générale des
finances. C'est quand même fascinant.
L'inspection générale des finances qui
est censée contrôler les doners de
l'État qui est devenue une passoire pour
permettre au aux eaux fonctionnaires de
pantoufler pour prendre ce que l'État
leur a donné et le donner au privés à
des banques d'affaires pour que les
banques d'affaires fassent du chiffre
d'affaires pour que les banes d'affaires
aient des commissions dans le cadre
d'opérations de fusion acquisition qui
ont été faites grâce au réseau que leur
amène c'est au fonctionnair
toujours le le verou de beril
et donc le le verou de ver c'est on y
reviendra mais c'est la question fiscale
elle est je pense que c'est un c'est
c'est c'est une autre dimension l'IGF
est pas sur la question les questions
fiscales et vraiment sur le contrôle des
des dépenses de l'État et comment est-ce
que l'État est géré. Et donc ce ce cette
ce corps de contrôle est devenu l'un des
vecteurs principaux de corruption de ce
pays. C'est-à-dire qu'il sert justement
à des personnes comme Emmanuel Macron à
gagner en 2 ans euh plus de 2 millions
d'euros. non pas du fait de son talent
contrairement à ce qu'on a prétendu mais
de son entre gens de sa capacité à
connecter des PDG de différentes
entreprises ceux de Nesle avec Pfizer et
cetera, qu'il avait rencontré grâce à
l'inspection ginance parce qu'il était
censé les contrôler parce qu'il était
censé s'assurer que ces personnes
servent le bien commun et non pour que
il puissent se servir à partir de là.
C'est ça qui a et ce discours qui est
quand même évident, qui est factualisé a
été subverti et les journalistes en cœur
l'ont présenté comme un mozard finance,
quelqu'un qui aura un talent particulier
et qui du fait de ce talent particulier
qui pourtant a été mis s'il l'avait eu
au détriment de du bien commun parce que
c'est millions d'euros qu'il a fabriqué
en quelques années. Pose de questions.
La première c'est est-ce qu'on croit en
une société où il est normal de gagner
des millions d'euros en très peu de
temps ? Donc gagner l'équil de ce qu'une
personne va tarder à gagner une vie ou
deux en quelques années. Déjà en soit,
c'est un problème parce que ça crée des
tensions au sein de la société très
fort. Ça c'est d'autant plus un problème
quand c'est sans provoquer de valeur
ajouté quelconque parce que quand vous
êtes banquier d'affaires, vous ne créez
rien pour l'économie. Vous ne créez rien
pour la société. Au contraire, les
fusion acquisition, la plupart du temps
elles ne débougent que sur une chose, la
suppression d'emploi. Pourquoi ? Au nom
de la rationalité, de l'optimal et
cetera. Mais tout simplement parce qu'il
faut payer tous ces intermédiaires. Ces
millions d'euros, il faut bien qu'ils
viennent de quelque part. Donc il faut
trouver des sources de revenus qui
permettent de redistribuer et cetera. Et
donc cette personne là va être non pas
présentée pour ce qu'elle est quelqu'un
qui s'est vendu et qui a trahi la cause
qui était censée défendre mais comme
quelqu'un qui seurait aurait un talent
particulier et qui du coup justifierait
le fait qu' elle arrive aux plus hautes
fonctions de l'État. Et ce que je décris
dans le livre c'est que c'est que non
cet homme en fait ne s'est construit
qu'en pillant du capital d'État.
C'est-à-dire Christian Eker qui était
secrétaire d'état au budget sous
Hollande raconte l'obsession de Macron
quand il était secrétaire général de
l'Élysée puis quand il était ministre de
l'économie privatisé. Les privatisations
d'aéroport de Paris, de la française de
jeu et cetera étaient déjà proposé par
Emmanuel Macron quand il était d'abordé
comme concier de Macron puis après comme
ministre d'économie. Pourquoi est-ce
qu'il faisait ça ? Aucune raison. On l'a
vu avec les débats avec de Paris. Il n'y
a aucune justification économique ou
autre à ces privatisations.
C'est pour c'est pour prendre voilà
piller du capital d'État, brûler du
capital d'État.
l'offrir à des interlocuteurs qui
derrière vont appuyer en retour. Arnaud
Lagarder, propriétaire de Paris Match,
le JDD Europain et cetera héritier. Euh
là par là là on frise la diffamation
mais j'ai de quoi le justifier d'une
débilité profonde vraiment quelqu'un de
ben vraiment c'est d'une d'unun manque
d'intelligence extraordinaire reconnu
hein par même au sein du petit Paris.
Sauf que on a un problème, c'est le fils
unique de Jean-Luc Lagard qui était un
grand capitaine d'industrie à qui l'État
avait confié un certain nombre
d'instruments pour le gérer pour essayer
pour essayer de le développer. Donc je
l' garder notamment qui va participer à
la création de ADS qui devient Airbus en
y ajoutant enfin en fusionnant Matra et
l'aérospatial. Je la Garner quelqu'un
dont on peut considérer que la fortune
quelque part pouvait éventuellement se
justifier du fait de ce travail qu'il
avait fait industriel pour essayer de
monter des grands géants et cetera. Sauf
que Arnaud Jean-Lard pardon a le malheur
de faire un enfant qui n'a pas les
compétences. Voilà, enfin ce qui peut
arriver dès que vous êtes dans un
capitalisme d'héritage, bah ça pose
problème. Évidemment, parfois ça marche
la loterie génétique parfois ça marche
pas. Et Arnaud Garder hérite de cet
empire industriel et évidemment Arnaud
Garder au bout de quelques années
détruit cet appareil industriel. On
parle quand même du principalionnaire de
Airbus. On parle quand même de le
l'industrie la plus importante au niveau
européen euh qui était détenue par une
personne.
C'était c'était peut-être clair qui
n'était pas favorable, le marché était
pas favorable
et et donc cette personne dévaste euh
son empire industriel, du coup se
retrouve en manque de liquidité. Manque
de liquidité parce que il commence à
être à cours d'argent. Il avait essayé
de de remonter son sa participation au
sein du groupe de son père. Il y arrive
pas. Et donc il doit se débarrasser des
actions de ADS. Et donc il va voir
l'Élysée, il va avoir un certain
d'Emmanuel Macron. quand il était
conseiller de Hollande et ils vont
monter ensemble une opération qui va
permettre à à la Garder de récupérer
près de 100 millions d'euros de
dividende personnelle sur une opération
qui en tout va rapporter 1,8 milliards
d'euros à son groupe par une série de
rachats en fait qui va être piloté par
l'État même si l'État ne va pas racheter
directement les actions mais qui va
faire acheter quelques actions à à EADS
par EADS elle-même et le reste en fait
par une opération de de mise en march
sur le marché bien sûr
et qui va permettre donc à à la Gardè de
récupérer ses 100 millions d'euros de
dividende. Or, il se trouve que la
Garder avait été client de Emmanuel
Macron chez Rotchill quelques années
auparavant, premièrement, et que
la Garder va être un des instruments
principaux de la propulsion d'Emmanuel
Macron dans l'espace public une fois
qu'il était copté au sein de ces étites,
il faut bien un moment le présenter au
peuple. On est encore dans une similie
démocratie. Il y a quelque chose qui
s'appelle les élections. Il faut un
moment quand même donc il va avoir une
stratégie de propulsion médiatique avec
les 29 unes de Paris Match et compagnie
qui vont se mettre en place. Et il y a
quelque chose de fascinant. Il y a un
livre qui s'appelle Mimi qui est sorti
en septembre 2018,
mi Marchand
qui est porte sur M Marchand, la reine
des paparadis euh de Paris qui est celle
qui qui alimente en ragot, en secret et
en photos vololéous grandes rédaction
femmes qu'on
personnage sulfureux,
bah je sais pas si sulfureux mais en
tout cas condamné pour trafic de
stupéfiant après s'être faite guler avec
500 kg de hachich dans une camionnette
et puis après toute une série d'autres
choses mais
consommation personnelle
consommation personnelle 500 kg et et à
partir de là en fait elle va elle va
construire un réseau qui va s'appuyer
sur des policiers verreux, le milieu des
toute une série d'informateurs qui vont
lui permettre de rentrer dans ce milieu
du marché de l'information du petit
Paris et de s'y faire un nom. Et donc ce
livre présente Mchand comme l'instrument
de l'ascension d'Emmanuel Macron en
disant c'est grâce à elle qu'il a eu
toutes ses unes dans tous ses médias et
cetera. On se rappelle hein, c'était une
opération de communication massive et
soudaine avec et et on sait on sait par
exemple que les paparazad qui av été
faites de Brigitte et Emmanuel Macron
dans Paris Match étaient des fausses
paparazad. C'est-à-dire qu'en fait,
elles étaient organisées avec l'accord
de Macron. Et donc c ce ce livre nous
apprend une information importante,
c'est que c'est Xavier Niel qui dans son
palais qui est une reproduction du trian
de Versailles en marbre rose dans 16e
arrondissement présente Mchand donc
personnage de grande qualité à Brigitte
Macron Xavier Niel qui a rencontré MAR
comment parce que Xavier Niel est passé
par la prison aussi euh à la santé. Bon
la cellule VIP he on met pas des
milliardaires en euh en prison sans
raison. Euh, il était soupçonné de
proxénétisme après avoir fait sa fortune
dans Minitel Rose et une série de pip
show de de sites de pip show et en fait
qui cachait un réseau de prostitution.
Alors, au bénéfice du doute, euh, il y a
une ordonnance de renvoi émise par
Renovan Runbeck à qui Sinel a rendu des
hommages appuyés depuis qui a indiqué
qu'il n'était peut-être pas au courant.
Moi ce que je raconte dans le livre,
c'est qu'en fait il y a eu une sorte
d'opération qui a permis de masquer un
certain nombre de preuves essentielles
pour empêcher cette personne qui était
déjà trop influente d'aller en prison.
Donc Xavier rencontre Mchand du fait de
son passage en c'est enquêté sur des et
c'est là la force du texte imprimé de ce
de cet ouvrage par rapport au grave ce
que vous assenez
au texte au textes que j'avais mis en
ligne c'est que il y avait toute une
partie d'enquête qui était renforcée
depuis j'ai rencontré les gens qui ont
été dans l'intimité de ces personnes-là
j'ai rencontré des personnes qui ont été
exploitées par ces personnes-là parce
que Xaviniel par exemple maltraite ses
employés les paye de façon extrêmement
faible et a créé en fait beaucoup
d'amertum chez un certain nombre de ces
personnes-là qui ont vu cette personne
dotée de capitaux extraordinaire qui les
réduisait en fait à des positions de
misère et ils ont voulu raconter le
l'envers du décor de cette machine en
fait de cet homme qui est censé partie
de rien avoir construit un empire et
comment en fait il s'appuyait sur toute
une série de compromissions successives
et de rapports de de
d'instrumentalisation de ces de ses
rapports pardon avec l'État avec les
haut responsables politiques. J'ai dont
j'ai été le témoin parce que quand
j'étais jeune en janvier 2014 avec
Xaviniel et qu'il m'annonce qu'Emmanuel
Macron veut devenir président de la
République alors qu'il n'est encore
personne. Juste un conseiller. Même
problème avec Henry Armand
personnellement.
Vous avez eu le même problème avec dans
quel sens ?
Dans le sens où il nous a annoncé que
c'était le prochain président de la
République.
Que en rièement vous avez dit ça ? Ben
bien sûr en rièement sauf qu'en rèement
n'a pas du tout le même pouvoir que
Xaviniel qui je vous le rappelle quand
même à l'époque est propriétaire du
monde de l'OBS de Telerama la vie et
j'en passe et a des participations
minoritaires dans à l'époque
backschifish qui existait Médiia part
tout toute une série d'autres médias en
rièement va créer le 1 et va y recruter
Rick Fotorino de façon très assumée pour
faire élire Emmanuel Macron pour
participer à l'élection d'Emmanuel
Macron. Il va financer je raconte aussi
la vie privée d'Emmanuel Macron.
L'ironie de de dans hier, c'est que
c'est en fait, il a fait fortune, donc
c'est quelqu'un qui a toujours alimenté
les réseaux de la deuxème gauche
rardienne donc que j'ai décrit là, les
les craqus et compagnie, enfin ce qui
est devenu les craques et compagnie en
rièrement fait sa fortune en créant les
centres commerciaux en France, en créant
cette sorte de machine à détruire le
petit commerce et machine à détruire le
lien social qui ont provoqué les gilets
jaunes infinés. Donc cette personne-là,
cette personne-là est celle qui décide
de prendre sous son aile Emmanuel Macron
de financer sa vie privée en lui faisant
après qu'il va lui permettre de
s'acheter un appartement, finançant ce
voyage de nos à Marrakech et cetera de
façon quand même assez étrange hein.
C'estàd que quelle est votre éthique
individuelle quand vous acceptez de vous
de vous faire financer comme ça par un
un un vieux monsieur qui va en fait
servir votre projet politique sans aucun
moment vous dire mais attendez quand
même moi j'ai peut-être mieux je vaux
peut-être mieux que ça déjà enfin c'est
quand même des choses c'est des rapports
humains qui sont quand même très
particuliers de don contre don qui sont
qui sont franchement gênants. Donc c'est
en rèement les Macrons. D'ailleurs,
c'est intéressant quand vous lisez
Macron Leak, donc les mails qui ont été
révélés de de cinq conseillers
d'Emmanuel Macron, voyez comment il est
mis sur la touche progressivement une
fois qu'il a joué il a joué son rôle et
une fois que d'autres personnes plus
importantes comme Bernard et cetera
peuvent prendre le relais. Et et vous
voyez en fait comment la cette personne
dépérit jusqu'à mourir euh à quelques
mois avant la fin de la campagne
présidentielle en écrivant des mails à
des petits jeunes qui vont devenir
députés euh comme Pierre Personon et
quelques autres euh en disant "Mais
est-ce que vous avez des nouvelles des
manuels
Donc lui que monsieur Macron
prétendait être son héros, une personne
qu'il avait sonor et cetera, l'a
complètement évidemment mis de côté une
fois qu'il n'avait plus besoin de lui.
Bon ben et ça moi ça fait écho justement
avec ce réflexe que j'ai vis-à-vis de
Richard Descoin en 2012 moment. Je dis
bon cette personne ça ve dire est-ce que
est-ce que vous restez fidèle à
l'individu à un moment où est-ce que
vous vous pensez à votre intérêt, vous
continuez vous faites et et j'ai un tel
dégoût pour les personnes qui sont
capables, elles sont tellement
nombreuses dans ce petit paris parce que
c'est une c'est un darwinisme social. Il
y a une lutte pour la place et pour
l'existence sociale qui est d'une
violence tellement exacerbée qu'elle
vous fait oublier tous vos tous vos
idéaux. Elle vous fait oublier d'où vous
venez et cetera et elle est construite
dès le berceau des ces lissau privé que
je décris.
C'est c'est c'est un c'est un élevage en
tout cas c'est que les lycées que je
décris Franklin l'école acienne dans mon
livre et cetera, les écoles pardon qui
vous prennent la trisème de maternelle
qui vous portent jusqu'en terminal pour
qu'ensuite vous puissiez réussir
brillamment des concours. Des
grandes écoles respectables.
C'est des écoles des endroits en fait où
vous êtes élevés pour intégrer cet
espace social là. On va vous donner
l'habitus qui va vous permettre en fait
de réussir les concours, de réussir à
vous intégrer dans cette société, d'en
respecter tous les codes.
Est-ce que vous vous les chargez pas
parce que vous avez quand même un
ressenti face à eux ? Vous avez
peut-être souffert sur place, persécuté
par vos copains d'école.
Est-ce que parce que assé que
non je pense que c'est ma c'est ma
grande force et que non ces gens m'ont
m'ont courtisé. Ça c'est là où on peut
même pas me faire ce procès en amertume,
c'est que encore une fois des gracs à à
enfin à tous les réseaux des coins en
passant par enfin on a essayé de
m'intégrer dans ces réseaux de socialité
et c'est et c'est moi qui m' un moment
me suis dit mais c'est pas ces gens-là
ne sont pas admirables. Ces gens-là
n'ont rien de n'ont rien à m'apporter.
Il y a pas ils n'ont pas de valeur
humaine, ils n'ont pas d'idée, ils n'ont
pas de ils sont juste là pour avoir une
place sociale. Alors moi cette place
sociale, je ne la désire pas en soi.
C'est pas mon intention n'est pas de de
me laisser absorber par le petit Paris
pour devenir quelqu'un juste pour être
quelqu'un qui en fait derrière la la la
façade ne sera rien. Et
je vous ouvre une parenthèse.
Ouais.
Euh j'ai j'ai trouvé un tweet cet
après-midi en préparant l'interview.
Ça dit bon, malgré cette insignifiance,
ce rastignacost est assez désagréable.
Finissons-en.
Branco n'est pas normalien, il a juste
fait valider sa thèse merdique par
copinage. Copinage et résotage sont les
deux mamelles des inutiles
êtres et prétentions intellectuelles.
Oui. Alors ça ça fait partie des trolls
Macronis qui essaie vraiment de de me
démonter. Pour le coup, c'est de la
diffamation mais c'est pas intéressant.
Moi, j'ai mis ma thèse en ligne avec les
rapports de jury et cetera qui ont été
quand même présidés par un professeur au
Collège de France, des professeurs de
l'École normale supérieure, enfin les
vraiment les euh l'élite en terme
universitaire du pays, les personnes les
les moins corrompables d'ailleurs
corruptibles pardon qui qui soit. Euh
j'ai bien sûr évidemment fait normal
avant, normalien, je suis rentré par les
concours de des admissions parallèles,
c'est-à-dire par l'université, par la
voie universitaire. J'ai pas fait de
prépa, j'ai fait sciences avant. et et
l'université à côté et euh et je trouve
ça intéressant ces procès en
illégitimité qui essayent de on a on a
beaucoup essayer de le faire dans un
premier temps pour essayer de me faire
terire. C'est-à-dire on a vraiment
essayé de m'écraser en disant "Mais non,
vous n'êtes pas vous n'êtes pas des
nôtres. Vous et il y a eu l'article de
l'Express aussi qui cherchait de la même
façon à essayer de m'évincer de l'espace
social bourgeois en faisant croire que
bah rien finalement parce que
contrairement à quelqu'un sur Twitter,
ils peuvent pas se permettre de diffamer
ouvertement." Donc ils étaient ils
essayaient d'insinuer sans réussir à
parce que dans les faits en fait il n'y
avait aucune possibilité de euh de
m'attaquer. Et non au contraire moi
j'étais dans une grande un grand mépris
pour ces jeux de copinage et de je me
suis toujours tenu à distance en fait de
ces effetsl
rally jalm de de petites choses comme
ça.
Alors j'ai fait si alors c'est
intéressant par curiosité j'avais fait
un rally quand j'avais 16 ans 15 ans. On
m'a invité, on m'a invité à un rally et
et j'ai vu bah avec les parents, les
enfants, enfin ce qui est assez il y a
rien rien de spécial à raconter. C'est
vraiment on va essayer de de faire s'ac
coupler euh les porteurs de capital
économique, social, symbolique et cetera
entre eux pour essayer de et non, j'ai
beaucoup de mépris pour ces choses-là, y
compris lorsqu'elles sont de mon camp.
Par exemple, on m'a très souvent invité
à quelque chose qui s'appelle le dîner
du millénaire. Alors, je félicite pas
ceux qui les organisent d'avoir trouvé
ce titre parce que vraiment pour faire
croire au complot, c'est qui sont je
pense que c'était une façon d'ironiser
sur les dîners du siècle et en fait
c'est toute une partie de
l'intelligentia de gauche qui essaie de
se retrouver entre elles pour se
socialiser, se rencontrer et cetera et
moi j'aurais répondu quand
on va pas été invité quand
quand ils m'ont proposé d'y aller, je
leurais dit mais moi je je m'attaque pas
à à ces modes de fonctionnement pour les
reproduire y compris avec des gens qui
penseraient enfin vous voyez c'est pas
ça n'a aucun sens pour moi quoi. Donc
donc non, j'ai toujours eu et de la même
façon quand des coins avaient voulu
m'intégrer dans le dispositif sarcosiste
et cetera, j'ai tout de suite impossible
et pareil en rupture avec Philippe Etti
lorsqu'ils avaient abandonné les leur
projets de réforme, je pense que c'est
pas un c'est pas un point sur lequel on
réussira à me à à m'attaquer ni à
m'avoir. Et cette violence sociale qu'on
qu'on essaie de m'infliger en essayant
encore une fois de m'exclure de là est
assez assez insignifiante et en même
temps révélatrice. C'està-dire que par
exemple sur la question Normalien, c'est
très intéressant. Moi, je me suis battu
en fait comme un chien pour que les les
personnes qui qui font leurs études
anormales, une fois qu'elles sont
admises et qu'elles font le cursus
honorarum de 4 ans enfin 3 ou 4 ans
selon vous êtes étudiant ou élève et le
même statut et le même statut ce qui est
le cas dans toutes les autres écoles de
de la République et et en fait pendant
des années les Normaliens
qui étaient issus du concours ont b se
sont battus mais vraiment violemment
pour que ceux qui venaient de
l'université qui ont pourtant font qu'on
face à des procédures de sélection plus
sélectives encore en terme de
pourcentage que celle de
de des classes prépram mais qui sont
beaucoup plus diverses socialement et
cetera n'est pas ce statut là n'est pas
le droit aux avantages auquels ils
avaient le droit et cetera et et on a
fini par gagner et on a fini par avoir
droit à l'appellation normalien quel que
soit le et et donc en fait je vis encore
tous les stigmates de cette période là
où j'avais fait une tribune en
libération et cetera pour essayer de de
montrer que ces formes d'apartail social
à des à des échelles microscopiques he
ridicules. C'estàdire c'est qui est-ce
que ça intéresse à part le tout petit
Paris et en même temps on voit bien
comment les échelles de distinction sont
essentielles où en fait on essaie de
s'accaparer des titres pour essayer de
se distinguer. On voit en fait que ça ça
fonctionne comme une grande cour au sens
aristocratique du terme et que oui, on
est on est tous en concurrence pour
essayer d'accaparer et d'obtenir la
place. Aujourd'hui, je suis dans une
forme d'indifférence assez grande sur
cette place là. J'ai démontré ce que
j'avais démontré. J'ai fait une test qui
était primée et imprimée, ce qui est
très rare par un institut universitaire
et la LGDJ et voilà. Après enfin on peut
dire "Ah oui, il a fait Yel mais il a
fait enfin enfin je sais pas on peut
faire mon mon cursus enfin en détail
hein. C'est j'ai toujours été très
rigoureux à ce niveau-là parce que je
sais très bien à quel point en fait
c'est très difficile de de
C'est une façon de vous armer en
prévision de des des
C'est ça. Moi en fait, j'ai eu une phase
d'accumulation de capital extrêmement
forte, extrêmement forte, symbolique,
très consciente, qui visait de façon
presque à vide à à avoir tous ces
vecteurs de légitimation qui fassent que
ma parole ne puisse pas être écrasée
dans cet espace- là. J'ai pas passé
l'énat et j'ai fait normal notamment
pour qu'un éénarc jamais ne puisse me
regarder de haut. J'ai fait une thèse
après à l'ONS pardon pour justement
pouvoir leur leur leur contrer ça et que
du coup la question de la qualification
sociale ne puisse jamais mettre et que
ces personnes-là ne puissent jamais
penser que par du fait d'un concours
passé lorsqu'ils avaient 20 ans qui ne
visent à mesurer que leur capacité à se
conformer à l'ordre social existant. ces
concours ne vous permettant en rien de
révéler un génie ou quoi que ce soit que
jamais il puisse écraser ma parole à
travers ça et ça ne ça les rend ça les
rend fou et ce genre de tweet c'est
vraiment la et alors qu'en plus je
rajoute que bah de l'autre côté
quelqu'un comme comme Emmanuel Macron
qui joue de ça à bloc pour le coup
vraiment et lui contrairement à moi pas
pour se défendre mais pour écraser
l'autre cette personne a raté trois fois
et non pas deux comme on le croyait Marc
Andvel un grand journaliste
d'investigation me l'a appris l'école le
concours de l'école normale justement
qu'il a raté le concours de l'ENA une
première fois avant d'avoir qu'il a
passé ses 5 ans d'affilé de sa vie, les
plus belles années de sa vie, a préparé
laborieusement des concours pour se
faire intégrer à ce système. Coûte que
coûte en fait, coûte que coûte. Son
obsession, c'était d'intégrer ce système
et qu'évidemment derrière, il n'allait
pas le questionner. Une fois qu'il avait
fait cet effort massif pour pour en être
le l'incarnation, comment est-ce que
vous voulez qu'il prenne ses distances
et qu'il disent "Mais non, mais ce
système en fait ne fonctionne pas. Ce
système ne sert pas la société." Cette
personne n'a aucun moment fait un geste
pour servir la société. C'est comme ça
qui est sidérant. elle n'a fait que
tenter de se reconnaître euh par euh par
par cette société qu'il est censé
réguler, contrôler, réformé et cetera au
nom des 99 autres % de la population qui
n'y ont pas accès ne veulent pas y avoir
accès ou tout simplement qui vivent et
qui financent. Parce que ces gens-là qui
se croient des génies à qui on convainc
parce qu'ils ont fait un an de prépa, 2
ans de prép ou qu'ils ont réussi
concours et cetera qu'on qui croient
qu'on leur doit quelque chose. Alors que
ces personnes-là, c'est nous qui avons
financé leurs études. C'est nous qui
leur avons permis d'accéder à ces
positions sociales que ces positions
sociales n'existent que parce qu'elles
sont censées servir de la société. Elles
sont censées apporter quelque chose au
reste des Français.
Ces personnes-là en fait ont
complètement oublié
d'où venait leur leur privilège
et et et je vais répondre à cette
question mais ils ont complètement
oublié. Je pense c'est là où ils sont,
je pense c'est une question de
conscience, ils ont complètement oublié
qu'il y a des personnes qui qui
souffrent au quotidien pour leur
permettre d'avoir cette place là et et
mais on a intégré un imaginaire dans
lequel il se croi supérieur et qu'à
partir de là ça leur est dû et ils
peuvent en profiter. Ils peuvent comme
Benjamin Griot partir dans le privé
gagner 17000 € par mois pour défendre
des législations qui vont permettre à
des entreprises privées de gagner de
l'argent alors en en s'appuyant sur ces
réseaux obtenus dans l'État pour servir
ces personnes-là. avant de revenir comme
porte-parole euh du gouvernement pour
parler des euh des Français qui euh qui
fument des euh des cigarettes enfin des
des gitanes et et roulent en diesel en
disant que c'est pas sa France à lui.
Bah cette personne-là s'est retrouvée a
vu sa porte défoncée par un Fick et je
peux vous dire que j'ai pas regruté que
ce soit le cas.
Est-ce que c'est une mafia tout ça ?
C'est un
c'est un Ouais, c'est ça. On peut c'est
une forme de cast. Ouais. de cas
corrompu, franchement corrompu, parce
que quand encore une fois quand vous
êtes prêt à privatiser l'aéroport de
Paris fil
fil mais non mais c'est là où c'est la
la phrase la plus importante de mon
texte, ils ne sont pas corrompus, ils
sont de la corruption. Ils ont réussi à
établir un système dans lequel la
corruption est devenue légale. C'est ça
qui est très important de dire, c'est
ils savent faire parce qu'ils maîtrisent
les codes. C'est eux qui font la loi,
c'est eux qui font la la il faut c'est
leur fonction dans la société. c'est en
tant que conseiller d'État, députés et
cetera de faire la loi et ils ont
construit un système dans lequel ce
qu'ils font est légal ou d'apparence
légale mais va leur permettre
d'accaparer des privilèges et de mettre
en place des politiques publiques qui
vont aller à l'encontre du bien commun,
à encontre de la République, de la chose
publique, de la républicain. Et donc ce
que je décris, c'est vraiment ça, c'est
que moi en fait dans du paralégal, du
légal, du ils réussissent en fait à
contourner les appareils de contrôle qui
sont censés dans toute démocratie qui se
respecte, empêcher que cette corruption
se mette en place pour la légaliser en
quelque sorte et s'assurer que leur
position restera restera installée. Et
c'est pour ça que ce livre est
inéditable en France théoriquement parce
que ce que je révèle, c'est c'est des
choses qui légalement sont très
difficiles à sanctionner.
Des procès
et et c'est là où c'est très
intéressant. Aucun procès. Aucun procès.
Oui, mais en novembre normalement la
diffamation c'est 3 mois. Donc c'est
théoriquement c'est fait. Et là dans et
en même temps, c'était impossible de le
faire éditer malgré l'immense succès et
l'immense importance de cet ouvrage,
impossible d'éditer. Et il a fallu que
une éditrice euh Marion Mazori qui est
au diablo qui anime donc pas dans le
petit Paris, vous voyez qui qui
reçoivent dans un rond-pois le texte
imprimé et qu'elle appelle sa messen euh
qui est Vera Michelski qui n'est pas
française mais suisse
héritière des laboratoires roches, donc
une autre oligarchie mais qui justement
est moins dans un lien avec les médias
et cetera. Donc une grande héritière et
Verwski quand elle l'appelle, lui il dit
"Ah mais on vient de m'envoyer le PDF,
je rentre dans un avion, je dis, je te
dis et euh en sortant l'avion, elle a
dit écoutez euh euh allez-y euh ça
coûtera ce que ça coûtera, c'est trop
important et il faut le sortir." Et à
côté d'elle, il y a Florent Masso qui
est un éditeur très courageux qui a
sorti notamment euh Merci pour ce moment
de Very Trader quand il était aux
arènes. Quelqu'un qui est habitué à à
prendre des risques très importants euh
qui s'est allié avec elle euh grâce à
Denis Robert donc le journaliste qui est
arrivé à faire Clearstream qui fait la
préface et qui euh qui garde un courage
extraordinaire qui a vu sa vie détruite
pour avoir dit la vérité comme quelques
autres et et ils sont dit qu'il fallait
qu'il fallait accompagner ce texte. On y
allait, ça a failli capoter à plusieurs
reprises parce que les avocats étaient
très inquiets. Il signalaient des
passages qui parce que le droit français
est fait pour protester protéger la
sphère bourgeoise. Il est construit à
cette fin. Et donc à partir de là, vous
voyez bien en France dans une justice de
classe, vous avez évidemment pas du tout
les mêmes risques juridiques que vous
apparteniez à une ou une autre sphère de
la société, des copains
et euh et moi face cette chose
complètement dégoûtante. La première
chose évidemment de salubrité publique,
c'était de le raconter et de prendre le
risque. Et je pense que j'ai eu la
chance de pouvoir prendre ce risque
parce que parce que moi j'ai rien. Et
c'est là où je disais que j'ai une
appartenance d'apparence seulement à
cette classe sociale. Mes parents sont
propriétaires de rien. Moi non plus.
C'estàd qu'on a très bien vécu. Mes
parents, mon père était producteur de
cinéma. Il faisait partie de cette élite
qui était nourrie par la gauche
culturelle 80. Sauf que lui,
contrairement à à la plupart des autres
et les rares qui qui ont pensé comme lui
ont tous très mal fini, suicider,
overdose et cetera, il s'est dit "Cet
argent n'est pas à moi. Cet argent, on
m'en confie la gestion pour produire
quelque chose qui va faire rayonner le
pays." Et mon père était quelqu'un qui
venait d'un petit village portugais. Il
avait fuit la dictature salazarienne
comme un mère d'Espagne sous la
dictature franquiste
et euh et était venu en France parce
qu'il avait été éduqué chez jésuite dans
l'admiration de notre culture et il
était venu avec il considérait comme un
miracle le fait qu'on lui donne la
possibilité de produire des films et de
et de permettre à des grandes œuvres
d'exister de et de faire de s'inscrire
dans cette histoire autant long donc
autant vous dire qu'il s'en ficha
complètement des stratégies de
patrimonialisation d'insertion dans
l'espace social et cetera et donc il
s'est retrouvé après avoir brassé au
cours de 30 ans de carrière de
producteur plus 300 films, des millions
et des millions sans un sous sans un
sous sans rien à lui en ayant fait
failli plusieurs fois à chaque fois
parce qu'à chaque fois il réengageait ce
qu'il gagnait dans la production de
nouvelles et ben tout ça ça crée un
rapport au monde en fait qui fait que à
un moment ben vous avez vous avez peur
de quoi finalement de perdre quoi vous
retrouvez çaa malgré tous vos titres et
cetera vous dites bah moi il faut il
faut faire voir quoi. Il faut moi j'ai
je pour quel intérêt bourgeois j'aurais
à défendre. Non, moi j'ai j'ai j'ai j'ai
refusé de rentrer tout ça et devenir
l'un d'eux. C'est pour me pouvoir garder
cette liberté, pouvoir à un moment dire
mais non mais j'accepte pas de devenir
l'un d'entre vous. Et ma meilleure façon
de ne pas accepter ça, c'est de dire la
vérité, de dire ce que vous êtes en fait
les systèmes et de permettre en fait aux
personnes qui étaient en train de se
révolter à ce moment-là, les gilets
jaunes notamment, d'avoir les outils de
leur révolte. c'est de dire c'est pas
seulement on a une idée qui sont tous
corrompus et cetera, mais très
précisément de façon très factuelle et
sans que ce soit possible de le
contredire, comment ça se construisait,
comment ce système s'était mis en place
et comment il en on en était arrivé à un
effondrement complet de cette de cette
République que ces personnes étaient
censées défendre, qu'on finance pour
défendre, que ce soit les journalistes,
les députés, les ministres, ces
personnes-là, c'est des c'est des
personnes à qui on a octroyé des
privilèges, des positions sociales et
cetera pour défendre nos intérêts en
tant que société. Euh il y a eu un
article, c'est dans l'Express, c'est ça
?
Ouais.
Euh les journalistes sont venus vous
mordre les molets, vous attaquz sur
votre adolescence, des choses comme ça.
Oui. Alors, ils ont c'est drôle, ils ont
ils ont tweeté l'article comme ça trois
enquêteurs euh service enquête de
l'Express qui appartient à Patrick
Drahi, Bernard Mourad que j'ai plutôt
enfin qui a été dirigé par Bernard.
Nous, on a le monde aux fesses en ce
moment. Bah moi je vais l'avir parce que
comme je disais, cet article a été
retweeté par Raphaël B et Arien de
Chemin qui sont les deux principales
journalistes du monde d'enquête entre
guillemets qui sont des courtisanes de
la 5e République. En fait, c'est des
personnes qui euh qui récoltent les
ragots du pouvoir pour les pour les
redistribuer et euh en s'insérant dans
des logiques de pouvoir et de et de
conflit de entre au sein de cette caste
pour essayer d'en récolter quelques
miettes sans jamais l'interroger. Au
contraire, en s'en faisant les les
gardiens les gardiens de l'ordre établi,
euh ces personnes ont retweeté l'article
de l'express. Pourquoi ? parce que je je
révèle dans crépuscule notamment comment
est-ce que elles ont enfin en tout cas
Raphaël Bakier a participé à la censure
d'une enquête que j'avais produite pour
le monde sur Areva et et Uramine où
j'étais parti quand même risquer ma vie
au fin fond du Centrafrique pour essayer
de révéler comment est-ce que des
milliards, je parle de milliards euh de
fonds publics avaient été avait disparu
dans la nature sous l'auvergeon à une
époque où le directeur du lobbying de la
revait un certain Édouard Philippe.
et et cet article qui était maqueté dans
le monde prêt d'être publié a été
dépublié 48 he avant. Enfin, ils l'ont
ils ont annulé la publication 48 he
avant sur ordre de la direction donné à
Serge Michel puis après de semaines plus
tard au monde de magazine où on tentait
de le reproduire. Et Raphaël Baquet me
vous une haine tenace depuis à ce sujet
et en fait j'ai mis du temps à
comprendre pourquoi.
Euh parce qu'elle a l'impression qu'à
travers l'exposition de ses faits, je
l'attaque elle. Et évidemment qui
participe à ce genre de système en
conçoit une grande honte quand il est
exposé publiquement. C'est injustifiable
et donc il y a ça crée une une sorte de
comme ça de fixation. Sauf que ce
qu'elle a pas compris c'est que c'est
pas du tout elle en soi qui pose vos
questions. C'est justement le système
dans lequel elle s'insère. Et en fait
d'ailleurs elle qui a était plutôt de
bonne foi qui au contraire m'a aidé à
essayer de faire publier cet article et
qui se retrouvait avec ses contreordres
de la direction qui empêchait. Mais mais
le fait qu'elle se soit tue, qu'elle
n'est pas à un moment dénoncé cette
chose-là, qu'elle était pas dans un
capital renversé la chose et encore plus
humiliant que le fait d'avoir donné
l'ordre et cetera. Et j'ai vu il y a pas
longtemps un entretien de Jérôme Fenolio
qui est le directeur du monde euh dans
l'instant dans l'Instemm qui est une
émission catastrophique de supposé
critique des médias dans France interne
mais qui a cet avantage extraordinaire,
c'est qu'elle permet de voir ces hommes
qui sont en général dans l'ombre qui
font la fabrique d'information de notre
pays et qui participent à ces effets de
compromission. Et cette personne a le
cynisme et le culot mais ahurissant et
j'ai découvert ce qui était un menteur
de prétendre qu'il n'y a aucune
intervention de la part de ses
actionnaires Xavier Niel euh Mathieu
Pigas pour plus longtemps et feu Pierre
Berger dans le contenu du monde euh qui
fonctionne en toute indépendance et que
tout en s'étant vendu à des oligarques,
ça n'a eu aucune conséquence au
contraire et que c'est des actionnaires
merveilleux et cetera.
Cette personne
déjeune un mercredi sur deux avec Xavier
Niel et avec Louis Drefus qui est
l'homme de main de Xaviniel, le
directeur général du monde. Qu'est-ce
qu'ils se disent ? Pourquoi est-ce que
Xavier Niel ressent le besoin de
déjeuner un mercredi sur deux avec le
directeur des rédactions du monde ?
Enfin, le directeur du monde tout court
parce que le directeur de la rédaction
c'est L Pron. Euh et comment est-ce
qu'on peut penser que cela n'aurait pas
d'effet sur l'activité éditoriale du
monde ? Comment est-ce que l'on peut
penser que cette personne ne se contente
que de parler des partenariats avec
Snapchat et compagnie et pas des
recrutements promotion
? C'est ça. C'est pas un dîner comme
Jadas, c'est
promotion, recrutement, licenciement et
cetera au sein de la rédaction.
Évidemment que cette personne suit de
très près. Évidemment que cette personne
n'intervient jamais directement. C'est
pour ça qu'elle a nommé un directeur
général, Louis Refus qui a cette charge
là et qui a cette fonction là au monde à
la HPS avant aux rock et cetera. Et ces
personnesl en fait ne donnent pas
d'ordre direct. Ils n'ont pas besoin en
fait. qui conforme à la fabrication de
la la la mise en place de rédaction qui
fait que cette rédaction infinée va
suivre une certaine tendance idéologique
qui va convenir qui va convenir à leurs
intérêts. pensé que Xaviniel qui était
connu pour faire des procès de façon
massive aux journalistes qui a un passé
pourquoi parce qu'il voulait pas qu'on
invoque ce press ce passé trouble qui a
dit qu'il rachetait des médias pour
qu'il quand que quand il pr que quand un
journal l'emmerdait il prenait une
participation dedans pour pour qu'on
arrête de l'emmerder aurait cette
personne qui refuse d'investir dans les
médias qu' inv il a pris départ
c'està-dire qu'il il les met à l'os il
s'assure qu'il y a des plans d'économie
réguliers qui font que les les
journalistes sont sous pression c'est
qui sentent qu'ils peuvent s'en sort
qu'ils peuvent être sortis à un moment
ou un autre ou alors qu'en tout cas il
faut que c'est comment pensez que cette
personne-là n'aurait pas d'impact cette
personne là qui présente Mimi Marchand à
Brigitte Macron pour une raison c'est
raconté dans l'ouvrage Mimi et je
voudrais revenir sur cet ouvrage pour
vous expliquer pourquoi on a parlé euh
qui présente Mchand pourquoi parce que
il voulait faire terire Brigit Macron
était paniqué sur les rumeurs
d'homosexualité de son mari ces rumeurs
à l'époque qui tournaient dans le petit
Paris et elle avait peur quelque part
dans ce que c'est un signe l'ouvrage que
ce soit vrai et elle voulait savoir si
c'était vrai et et Niel la présente à à
Marchand.
Qui vous a dit ça ?
C'est dans le livre. C'est dans le livre
et il est présente.
Qui qui vous a dit ça dans le livre ?
Qui qui m'a dit ça dans le livre ?
Comment qui a raconté aux journalistes ?
Je peux pas vous révéler leur sauce,
mais j'ai parlé avec les journalistes
qui ont non dans le livre dans le livre
Mimi, pas dans pas dans le mien euh mais
j'ai parlé avec les journalistes qui ont
écrit Mimi qui m'ont raconté en fait un
peu les dessous de l'enquête et il
raconte cette rencontre donc entre
Brigitte Macron, Mi Marchant et Xaviniel
et et Mi Marchand lui dit si ces rumeurs
comme quoi il y aurait une photographie
d'Emmanuel Macron avec un homme était
vraie, moi j'aurais eu cette
photographie entre mes mains. Donc cette
cette photo cette photo n'est pas vraie
n'existe pas de la radio. Euh je sais
pas, je et là pour le coup euh ce serait
ça serait bas peut-être de relancer
quelque chose sans aucun élément. Voilà.
Mais la question la question
intéressante n'est pas là, c'est que
Xavier Niel propose le service de cette
personne pour que dans le cas où cela
avait été vrai qu'elle puisse contrôler
l'information fait. Donc vous avez un
oligarque, quelqu'un dont la fortune
dépend de l'État. Parce que la fortune
de Frix, contrairement à ce qu'on a dit,
c'est pas une fortune faite du néance,
c'est parce qu'il a eu des licences
d'abord comme opérateur internet puis
après comme opérateur téléphonique. Donc
l'État lui a donné moyen de rentrer dans
des marchés régulés qui font qu'il a une
rente qui nolens volens va lui permettre
d'avoir de l'argent quoi qu'il arrive en
fait et qui va permettre d'investir par
ailleurs et de multip. Cette personne à
fortune des points de l'État décide
d'aider un potentiel président de la
République à éventuellement masquer une
information si était vrai euh enfin sa
compagne et mais vous imaginez le
pouvoir que ça lui donne ? C'est que
imaginez que ça avait été vrai et Brig
Macron à ce moment-là ne savait pas.
Imaginez que le cette personne aurait pu
faire chanter le futur président de la
République toute sa vie parce qu'il
aurait su que l'information était vraie.
Il aurait pu décider un moment de la
sortir ou pas. Et même sans faire ça, il
se il se met dans une situation
d'emprise. Et cette Brigitte Macron qui
est quelqu'un qui rentre dans l'espace
parisien un peu tardivement après ven
qui qui a cette fragilité parce qu'on on
attaque sur son âge, on attaque sur les
rumeurs, sur mes sexualités et cetera,
trouve un accueil qu'elle pense
bienveillant auprès de ces personnalités
qui disent "On va vous aider, vous
inquiétez pas, Naana, mais" qui en fait
vont vont la mettre sur en prise et vont
s'assurer que ces personnes-là vont les
servir de la même façon qu'ils les ont
servis auparavant. On sait très bien
comment Xavier a eu sa licence
téléphonique dans la guerre de position
qui opposait Sarkozi et et Fillon. On
sait très bien comment Bernard Arnaud a
constitué sa fortune des années 80 en
récupérant Boussac pour un franc
symbolique de la part de l'État. Pus qui
était un grand groupe euh d'industrie
textile qui avait notamment Dior, les
parfums, Cardins et cetera euh contre
l'engagement ne pas licencier euh euh
des personnels ni de diviser le groupe.
Euh il va retoucher plus de 300 millions
de francs de subvention à cette fin de
la part du gouvernement Fabus à
l'époque. Euh il va licencier évidemment
3000 personnes. Il va évidemment
démanteler le groupe pour n'en garder
que les grandes marques et il va devenir
la première porte fortune française
grâce à ce cadeau que l' fait l'État. Or
évidemment, est-ce que euh est-ce que
c'était fait de façon désintéressée ?
Non. De la même façon que Mitteran avec
les élites culturelles, bah Fabius avait
un intérêt à se constituer un appui de
choix au sein de l'élite économique
parisienne qui dans la foulée allait
racheter un certain nombre de médias.
Aujourd'hui, on sait que Bernard Arnaud
est propriétaire du Parisien. Il a été
intervenu pour essayer de s'approprier
la tribune et cetera. Et donc en fait
ces personnes-là qui par ailleurs toutes
des jeunes d'inemble enfin Bernard Arno
a racheté l'hôtel particulier de
Jean-Luc Lagard à sa mort euh à la veuve
et il s'est installé dans une sorte de
revanche un peu égotique euh ils seront
Xavier Niel s'est marié avec la fille de
Bernard Arnaud qui parce qu'elle est la
fille de Bernard Arnaud dispose d'un
capital de 4 milliards d'euros euh
depuis sa naissance. Là ils ont une
fille qui s'appelle Elisa qui va devenir
la première fortune d'Europe du simple
fait d'être né. euh de parents qui sont
évidemment mariés par amour, hein, pas
par pas par intérêt. Vous voyez bien en
fait comment ce système qui va faire que
une petite dizaine de personnes qui sont
parmi les personnes les plus riches du
pays et qui contrôlent le monde
diplomatique l'a montré à plusieurs
reprises en détail 90 % de la presse
écrite du pays mais aussi un nombre de
radios, de télévision et cetera dont les
fortunes dépendent de la commande d'État
ou de la régulation de l'État de façon
plus ou moins directe. Évidemment
n'achète pas des médias par hasard.
évidemment n'achète pas des médias pour
pour se faire plaisir ou pour sauver la
démocratie. Ces personnes n'ont rien à
faire du système démocratique. Si la
France était démocratique, ces
personnes-là ne seraient plus pas dans
les positions de pouvoir qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui. Si la France ne
fonctionnait pas comme une oligarchie,
Bernard Arnaud n'aurait pas le pouvoir
qu'il a aujourd'hui. N'aurait pas 80
milliards d'euros de capital. 80
milliards d'euros doublé en 2 ans.
Comment est-ce que vous expliquez que
dans une société supposément
démocratique, de telles inégalités
puissent exister ? 80 milliards d'euros
à partir d'une fortune encore une fois
constituée avec l'aide de l'État de cet
état qu'ils veulent continuer à pomper
qu'ils veulent continuer à réduire parce
qu'ils ne veulent que s'accaparer des
choses. Bernard Arnaud quand même je
rappelle qu'il essayait de s'exiler
fiscalement en obtenant la nationalité
belge.
Ça 80 milliards d'euros. Est-ce que ça
vous suffit pour payer vos impôts ?
Visiblement non. et il voulait, il était
prêt à partir en Belgique après avoir
obtenu grâce à ce pays la France, grâce
à nous, grâce à grâce à l'effort de
chacun d'entre nous qui payons nos
impôts, tous les moins qui produisons de
la richesse et cetera, euh il voulait ne
plus payer ses impôts et partir en
Belgique et profiter de sa vie tout en
gérant nos actifs euh à distance. Et
bien cette personne-là, évidemment va
devenir l'un des principaux
bénéficiaires des politiques fiscales
mises en place par Emmanuel Macron,
suppression de l'ISF, flat taxe et
cetera. Exit taxe pour pour certains de
ses affilés, CICE.
qui bénéficie pour moitié aux grandes
entreprises du C40 dont le principal
bénéficiaire est Carrefour, Bernard
Arnaud est le 3è actionnaire de
Carrefour et ainsi de suite. Donc vous
voyez c'est un système qui se met en
place dans lequel l'idéologie est
complètement abandonnée. l'idéologie au
sens noble du terme encore une fois,
c'està-dire comment sublimer son
intérêt, comment un moment penser au au
profit du collectif et pas pour soi et
en soi et et c'est amené à un tel niveau
d'absurdité qu'évidemment ça provoque
une révolte hallucinante et qu'à un
moment les gilets jaunes arrivent non
seulement pour se révolter contre le
pouvoir économique, si on attaque plus
le MDEF aujourd'hui, c'est bien pour une
raison, c'est parce qu'on sait bien que
c'est pas là l'enjeu. l'enjeu est dans
le contrôle de l'espace médactique, dans
contrôle d'espace politique par ces
personnes-là, par les oligarques bien
au-dessus en fait euh du MDF et des
autres dispositifs de réseau qui
existent dans tous les pays qui sont
finalement assez secondaires
à cette fin. Et donc euh donc voilà, moi
face à ça en fait, face à cette prise
démocratique parce que un vote, une
démocratie enfin si vous votez à
l'aveugle, en quoi est-ce que vous êtes
une démocratie ? Si on peut vous faire
voter pour une chèvre, un lapin ou et en
vous faisant croire que la chèvre est le
lapin et le lapin est la chèvre, votre
vous êtes vous êtes désouverainisé.
votre vote ne sert à rien. Vous avez
l'illusion démocratique mais dans les
faits vous n'avez aucune possibilité de
peser sur votre propre destin. Donc
quand vous avez les élites médiatiques
qui vous trahissent, les élites
médiatiques et intellectuelles au sens
large, c'est pas un hasard s'il y a pas
un grand intellectuel à quelques
exceptions vraiment quelques exceptions
près qui sont mobilisées vraiment
franchement pour les gilets jaunes. pas
un média à part le monde diplomatique et
le média comme par hasard de de médias
qui ne dépendent pas de de ces systèmes
oligarchiques, qu'il n'y a pas
enfin un journaliste, un éditorialiste
important de ceux qui a qu'à part
l'antenne qui est pris qui est pris pied
pour ce mouvement et qu'on ait en au
contraire eu tous ces dispositifs de de
délégitimation les accusant
d'antisémitisme et cetera, c'est pas un
hasard, c'est une volonté de contrôle de
reprise de contrôle social face à des
individus qui ne demandent qu'une chose,
un approfondissement démocratique.
L'écart de perception avec le réel est
tellement ahurissant qu'il confirme en
fait la révolte des gilets jaunes. Le
pourquoi de la révolte des gilets
jaunes. C'est gilet jaunes se révolent
parce qu'on les a trahi, parce qu'ils
étaient ceux qui croyaient le plus en
système. C'est eux qui étaient les
fondements de la démocratie
représentative. C'est eux qui ont
accepté de déléguer leur capacité à
parler, leur capacité à prendre des
décisions en faisant confiance à ces
élites intermédiaires, députés,
journalistes et cetera, leur disant
"Vous, on vous donne la possibilité de
faire des études, on vous donne la
possibilité d'investir la matière
intellectuelle de façon à ce que vous
défendiez au mieux nos intérêts. On vous
fait cette confiance là." Or, ces
personnes ont trahi de façon si violente
qu'à un moment la base a dû se rebeller
et dire "Mais c'est fini, on vous
renverse".
Rendu compte, elle s'en est rendu compte
parce qu'il y avait plus loin parce que
c'est allé trop loin. Voilà. parce qu'on
s'est retrouvé dans la 6e position
mondiale avec des personnes qui
n'arrivaient pas à finir qui
n'arrivaient pas à manger, qui passaient
1 2 3 jours sans manger, à se retenir de
manger parce qu'ils arrivaient plus à à
boucler leur fin de mois et que au mois
de décembre
et les gens qui étaient au mois de
décembre, c'est des personnes qui qui
avaient qui étaient face à un enjeu
existentiel. C'est pour ça qu'ils ont
débordé les black et cetera. C'était pas
la révolution de salon, c'était pas on
vit sur le mode, c'était des personnes
qui jouaient leur vie et qui du coup
étaient prêtes à aller jusqu'au bout
évidemment. Et c'est pour ça que au
contraire on a prépositionné un
hélicoptère pour évacuer selon la presse
Emmanuel Macron d'Élysée. C'est pour ça
que Emmanuel Macron a fait visiter le
bunker antiatomique de l'é parce que au
contraire des personnes qui étaient
mobilisées, ceux qui étaient au pouvoir,
c'est pas qu'ils avaient peur, tout le
monde a peur, mais c'est que eux avaient
beaucoup à perdre et eux n'étaient là
que pour genre d'intérêt. Donc s'il
fallait se barrer, ils n'ont rien à
défendre si ce n'est leur propre
position sociale. Donc s'ils étaient
face à un risque d'effondrement, ils
partaient. Ils allaient pas quel com
pourquoi vous deviendrez héroïque quand
vous n'êtes là que pour servir votre
intérêt. Vous allez là où votre intérêt.
Bah s'il faut prendre un hélico et se
barrer, on se barre et on abandonne le
on abandon le poste. Très bien, pas de
problème. Si en fait donc vous voyez cet
écart extraordinaire entre ces
personnesl qui ne pensaient qu'à une
chose, c'était s'exfiltré et qui après
du coup ont mis en place toute une série
de dispositifs les primes pour les
policiers. Euh c'était c'était génial le
moment où Macron revient de Buenos
Aides. Euh au lieu de s'adresser aux
Français immédiatement après cet acte
apocalyptique en gros on a il y a eu
toutes quand même ces scènes qui est
révolutionnaires vraiment
insurrectionnelle massive. Il parle à
personne, il visite les champs avec les
policiers pour une sorte de
démonstration d'autorité un peu vaine.
Euh il déjeûne dans une caserne et il
annonce le soir, il fait annoncer par
l'Élysée des primes pour les policiers
et après ensuite il s'adresse au
français. Il a bien compris que la seule
base qui lui restait à lui qui n'était
là que pour piller, c'était les tenants
de l'ordre. C'était la police. Et
pourquoi est-ce qu'il sa prétorienne ?
Et je finis là-dessus et pourquoi est-ce
qu'il annule tous ses vœux en janvier,
sauf les vœux militaires ?
Sauf que c'est tellement énorme pour
nous qui avons été conformés par toute
cet espace médiatique aïé qu'on vit dans
une démocratie réelle et cetera. C'est
tellement difficile de se dire "Mais en
fait c'est exactement comme le régime de
Benali."
C'est qu'on on en est là qu'on en effet,
il y avait un hélicoptère qui était prêt
à l'exfiltrer, qu'il était prêt à se
barrer. Il s'en foutait complètement.
Enfin, vous voyez, c'est on c'est
tellement énorme de penser qu'on qu'on
est dans cette configuration là qu'on
qu'on censure. On se dit "Mais non, mais
on a sauf qu'il y il y a rien à répondre
à ça, au fait en fait, à l'accumulation
de fait évidente." C'est-à-dire que
cette personne-là, au lieu de rentrer
dans un rapport politique avec ce
mouvement social et d'y répondre
politiquement, a essayé de d'y répondre
en donnant quelques quelques miettes euh
sans à aucun moment poser la question du
système dans son ensemble.
Alors qu'évidemment la seule façon de
répondre aux revendications gilets
jaunes, c'était d'abord une réforme du
système qui ensuite permettrait
naturellement d'amener une
redistribution des richesses à une plus
grande égalité, à une réforme de la
politique fiscale et cetera. Non, lui il
il s'est dit on va on va corrompre,
c'est comme ça qu'il fonctionne, on va
donner quelques milliards pour les
calmer et derrière on va jouer l'ordre
et on va imposer par l'ordre et on va
imposer une répression extraordinaire.
3000 arrestations seulement en décembre
de lycéen
de lycéen.
Le mouvement lycéen commença à
s'enclencher. 3000 arrestation les
images les images à ment la jolie euh
des personnes des lycéens genou qui sont
filmé
et diffusé. C'est par hasard si elles
sont filmées et diffusé. Il y a
évidemment un effet d'intimidation très
forte de la même façon que le dispositif
en soi de mise à genou de ces
personnes-là qui est complètement
gratuit qu'on ne verrait que dans dans
un système autoritaire mais d'une
violence extraordinaire. Comment est-ce
qu'en France on arrive à des images
pareilles ? Moi, c'est à ce moment-là où
je décide de prendre le maqui au sens
large du terme, mais de dire "Moi, je je
neisai plus jamais à un système de cet
ordre là." Quand on est capable d'une
telle dégradation de soi, d'une telle
dégradation de mais symbolique hein,
mais pensé symboliquement et qu'on fait
arrêter 3000 jeunes pour empêcher que
ces personnes puissent se joindre à un
mouvement et manifester pour le 3000
personnes, des arrestations arbitraires
9000 en tout. Il y a probablement 8500
arrestations arbitraires parmi les 9000
qui n'ont qu'un seul objectif,
intimider, écraser un mouvement social
de la même façon que les 3000 blessés,
de la même façon que les 200 blessures
de guerre, les blessures de guerre les
21 borniers, c'est des c'est des
stratégies d'écrasement d'un mouvement
politique, d'un mouvement social. La
loi, la loi anticasseur,
ça on en avait parlé lors de notre
premier entretien danseriew quand on
parlait, vous m'avez posé exactement la
même question sur l'état d'urgence et je
vous avez fait cette réponse que que je
répète, c'est que le fruit en fait de ce
que je suis en train de vous décrire, ne
nous attardons pas sur le détail de de
du de la mise en place de ce système en
fait d'écrasement et d'imposition par
l'ordre de vertical autoritaire parce
que si on court après chaque expression
de ce système- là, on va on va perdre,
on va toujours perdre parce que ces
temps-là cette personnel pardon ont le
contrôle du tempo législatif, politique
et cetera et trouvons toujours une façon
de
on va on va on va on va se mettre à à à
moyen long terme. Là, les paramètres
économiques
sont dans une volatilité
apocalyptique. C'est le système
financier
commence à montrer des des
un stress important. Euh les mouvements
sociaux ne vont que s'accentuer
tant en longueur qu'en qu'en puissance
qu'en intensité.
Vous voyez quoi ? La France dans 3 ans,
c'est quoi pour vous ?
Il y a en fait il y a des il y a des
temporalités différentes qui se qui se
surperposent. Euh on est à à 3 jours
d'un d'un moment euh déterminant pour la
suite des gilets jaunes. Euh ce samedi,
il y aura euh l'acte 18 euh qui va
permettre en fait de
de mettre soit un point d'arrêt au
mouvement, soit au contraire de finir de
l'imposer comme une force politique
majeure qu'il faudra prendre en compte.
Il y a il y a des il y a mon ouvrage qui
cherche de la même façon à devenir un
point de bascule au sein de ce système
là, c'est-à-dire en exposer les
fondamentaux de façon à ce qu'il ne soit
plus possible de le reproduire. Euh
évidemment, je
il va disponible gratuitement sur
internet,
il est il est déjà dans cette version
PDF que j'ai mis dès novembre mais sauf
que là on a une version qui est beaucoup
plus puissante en fait parce qu'on en
plus on l'a renforcé et cetera. Il y a
que 10000 exemplaires qui vont être
disponibles. Je sort le 21 mars, mais
c'est surtout que euh
c'est un livre et un livre pour ces
personnes-là, c'est pas la même chose
qu'un PDF. C'est que cette chose est
gravée dans le marbre et ce texte, il va
rester quoi qu'il quoi qu'il le il
pourrait dit c'est une période clé
parce que c'est le le c'est la dernière
possibilité de vraiment provoquer une
bascule. C'estàd que soit on si ça
fonctionne pas, moi j'en ai parlé avec a
avec certains des des principaux
représentaux des des gilets jaunes, ces
personnes-là ont besoin de recommencer à
vivre et ils ont besoin de de gagner
leur vie. C'est des personnes, moi
Maxime Nicole qui est donc je suis
devenu euh son avocat mais surtout je
pense un un ami j'espère en tout cas euh
c'est quelqu'un qui va à chaque
manifestation en blablacar. C'est chaque
samedi, il trouve un blablacar pour
essayer de et et financièrement ça paye
sur lui et c'est quelqu'un qui parce
qu'il est intègre et honnête refuse
toute forme de don ou quoi que ce soit
du fait de sa position dans l'espace
social. Sauf que ça crée au bout de 3
mois un épuisement qui qui est similaire
en fait à l'ensemble enfin pour
l'ensemble des personnes qui se
mobilisent. Et donc ils ont décidé de
faire de cet acte de ce samedi qui vient
un moment de bascule. C'est dire voilà
maintenant c'est soit maintenant ou
jamais. C'est soit maintenant on y va
vraiment et on prend au sérieux euh la
crise à laquelle on est confronté
individuellement, socialement et cetera
et on essaie de provoquer cette bascule.
Soit il faudra penser à autre chose et
d'autres prendront le relais et ça sera
sous d'autres formes et avec parce que
de toute façon comme vous le dites en
effet la crise est systémique et euh et
c'est là où il y a quand même quelque
chose de fidérant dans le dans le dans
le dans le grand débat entre guillemets.
C'estàd
on pense qu'on peut répondre par des
mots à cette crise là. Évidemment que
les mots sont importants et quand vous
dites des Français qui ne sont rien et
cetera, tout en vous revendiquant
vous-même, d'être un brillant surgent de
l'élite et cetera, c'est extrêmement
violent et écrasant. Mais et mais ça ça
ça sera pas. Mais surtout, il y a une il
y a une il y a une crise, c'est il y a
des gens qui sont en train de mourir en
fait de et de la même
15000 morts euh c'est un chômage entre
selon l'INERME, donc un institut
statistique, l'Institut statistique sur
les questions médicales d'État, entre 10
et 15000 morts par an du fait du chômage
en France, du fait des suicides,
maladies et cetera, du chômage hein, je
parle pas de la précarité, de l'intérim,
de des des conditions de travail
difficiles et cetera. 10 à 15 millions
par si on on fait 30 ans de chômage de
masse, c'est 40 ans mais disons 30 ans,
c'est 4500 personnes.
C'est c'est un massacre de masse du fait
de l'impéricide de nos élites politiques
qui parce qu'elles sont préservées de
ces phénomènes là, parce qu'elles
s'insèrent dans ce système de ce petit
paris dans lesquels leurs intérêts sont
préservés de bout en bout
sont complètement indifférentes.
À cette question là.
On fait quoi ? C'est quoi la
préconisation ? On lit, on lit votre
bouquin, on va manifester au gilets
jaunes.
Ouais, on on renverse le pouvoir.
On s'endurcit, on s'endurcit la tête.
Non, on renverse le pouvoir. Moi, je
j'appelle la destinition de Macron dans
l'ouverture de de ce texte
et euh et il faut d'une certaine façon
ou d'une autre que ce pouvoir tombe. Ce
pouvoir au sens large positionuse,
c'est c'est une c'est c'est une remise
en question fondamentale d'un système
parce que est-ce que c'est Macron ?
parce que c'est non, c'est très
largement euh un système dans lequel des
personnes de peu de valeur ont accaparé
des ressources délirantes qui font
souffrir des millions d'autres
personnes. Moi, les gilets jaunes m'ont
sauvé et je pense m'ont sauvé la vie
parce que j'étais arrivé à un point
d'impasse absolu parce que c'est refus
de de mise en place de système de
compromission et je suis personne, enfin
moi aussi j'ai mes j'ai mes défauts et
cetera et je pense que la chance de ma
position aujourd'hui c'est de c'est
c'est de pas chercher à construire une
position sociale à partir de de ce que
je suis en train de faire maintenant.
Évidemment, il faudrait que je fasse ma
vie un moment ou un autre, mais c'est
plus dans une stratégie politique
d'entrée dans le système et cetera. Et
donc je me pose pas en position de de
sainteté ou quoi que ce soit vraiment.
et j'ai et encore une fois, je raconté,
j'ai participé à ce système. Si je le
connais, c'est parce que je l'ai connu
de l'intérieur. Je me suis laissé avoir
et beaucoup des personnes m'ont emporté
parfois par naïveté, parfois par vanité
et et si et je vois bien en fait comment
fonctionnent ces personnes, il s'agit
pas de les diaboliser. C'est pas des
monstres qu'on a en face de nous, c'est
des personnes qui un moment se sont
laissé emporter euh dans un système par
glissement successif et à un moment le
coût pour en sortir était trop important
pour eux et donc ils acceptaient la
compromission suivante et ainsi de
suite. Je suis convaincu qu'Edard
Philippe c'est quelqu'un d'humainement
très très affable, très agréable et
cetera. mais qui s'est vauté en fait au
fur des fils des années dans un système
auquel il n'aurait jamais dû mettre
pied. C'est pour ça que je crois dans
des bouleversements de système. Il
s'agit pas de couper la tête à X ou Y.
C'est pas ça. Macron c'est rien. Le
pauvre Macron qui à mon avis est
quelqu'un qui s'est fait avoir en fait
par vanité et cetera,
nucléaire. Le premier ministre
il a il a il a il a une capacité à
servir les intérêts qui l'ont soutenu,
le soutiennent et le système dans lequel
il est s'insère au sens large. Donc
c'est pas une question de complotisme et
cetera. C'est au sens large il a la
capacité à défendre un système existant.
Il a le pouvoir de Macron est inexistant
dans les faits. La capacité à vraiment
provoquer des bascules réels est
inexistant. On l'a bien vu ce mandat
qu'on nous promettait être celui de la
révolution et cetera. À quel à quel
moment cette personne a provoqué une un
changement de système ? Il a accru euh
ses ses échecs et ses insuffisances. Il
a accru l'injustice qu'il provoquait.
Mais à quel moment est-ce qu'il a
provoqué une vraie rupture dans
l'éducation haute ? Non. Enfin ça il son
pouvoir réel est extrêmement faible.
C'est ça qui est qui est assez fascinant
à voir en fait. C'est quelqu'un qui est
tenu qui est pris en fait dans les nces
de quelque chose qu'il a consacré et il
pensait à travers cette consécration
trouver sa liberté et au contraire il
s'est trouvé en prix dans un dans une
dans une absence de de capacité. On le
voit bien, il le dit lui-même. Il n'a
pas de solution. Il n'a pas de réponse.
Cette personne qui ne pense pas après 3
mois de grand débat n'a toujours pas de
réponse à apporter au français. Il
l'avait dit mi-janvier pendant un
déplacement au Virginie Malingre qui est
une journaliste du monde qui le suivait.
Il disait "Je sais si je savais ce que
ce que je devais faire. Je le ferai mais
j'ai envie de lui dire mec, tu es payé
par nous pour savoir ce que ce qu'on
doit faire et si tu sais pas, tu sors et
on réorganise une élection et on et à un
moment il faut quand même avoir quel
quel ne nous assomme pas de meeting de
propagande tous les 3 jours relayés
complaisément par les médias pour nous
donner l'impression que tout va bien
alors que la situation n'a pas changé ta
yota et prends tes responsabilités et
rends le pouvoir et rend le pouvoir pas
seulement en partant pas seulement par
une destitution d'émission et cetera,
mais en refondant le système. faire pour
le système évidemment passer par une
nouvelle constitution, une nouvelle
élaboration qui fasse que il n'y ait
plus 1 % parce que c'est drôle que ce
soit exactement les mêmes chiffres dans
les grandes écoles et assemblée
nationale 1 % d'ouvriers d'employés à
l'Assemblée nationale l'Assemblée
nationale n'a qu'une fonction c'est de
représenter le peuple
c'est sa seule fonction il nous sont
Macron avait les pleins pouvoirs pour
décider qui se présenterait aux
élections quel type de catégorie social
il a fait lire que des bourgeois à un
moment je veux dire quand à Quoi ser ?
Comment est-ce que vous voulez que les
gens rentrent chez eux lorsque tous les
systèmes de représentation politique ne
les représentent pas ? Il y a pas un
fils d'ouvrier ou d'employé qui
aujourd'hui dans une rédaction
parisienne. Il y a pas un ouvrier
employé qui aujourd'hui assemblé
nationale au Sénat. Il y a pas un
ouvrier ou un employé qui est au
gouvernement. L'Assemblée nationale,
c'est pas une question de compétence,
c'est une question de représentation,
c'est capacité à transmettre le vécu
d'une partie de la population qui fasse
qu'on aura beau vous expliquer oui,
rationnellement, économiquement, c'est
bien de faire cette taxe de de retirer
de l'argent au plus pauvres et cetera,
vous direz mais vous me racontez ce que
vous voulez. Non, on peut pas là. Là,
ces personnes v leur enlever 5 € de
d'APL, ça va faire un plein en moins, ça
va faire une journée à passer sans
manger. On peut pas ça et ça quelqu'un
qui va avoir être absorbé par les
statistiques, par une abstraction du
politique ne va jamais avoir la capacité
à dire bah non, il y a des personnes qui
sont dans la fin en fait et ces
personnes-là un moment ces personnes-là
il faut les porter aux politiques et
tant qu'on aura pas un système qui
représentera ces personnes-là, on aura
beau avoir les meilleures intentions du
monde, leurs intérêts ne seront pas
défendus parce que les effets d'habitus
et de défense de caste et d'intérêt et
cetera primeront toujours à terme, même
si encore une fois ces personnes de mis
intention et cetera. On l'a bien vu avec
l'embourgeoissement de la gauche
française qui par effet successif
affectent leurs politiques sociales
elles-mêmes sont devenues de plus en
plus en faveur des des bourgeois au
détriment des classes prolétaires. Et
ben moi moi qui ne suis pas marxiste qui
a jamais fait mes classes dans des
partis d'extrême gauche et cetera, qui
est qui est toujours accepté de
participer au système en y croyant et
cetera, à un moment quand vous êtes face
à une telle aberration, vous dites bah
il y a pas de solution interne propre
système. Il y a un moment il faut un
renversement de quelque forme que ce
soit. dans dans votre livre, vous
évoquez quelqu'un que vous connaissez
depuis la 6e,
euh un certain monsieur Atal, euh plus
jeune plus jeune conseil conseiller
d'état,
plus jeune ministre de la 5e réplique,
excusez-moi. Ou
plus plus jeune secrétaire d'état euh
vous lui en voulez ou
non, c'est quelqu'un qui qui m'indiffère
au plus haut point en tant que que
personne.
euh mais sur lequel qui me permettait en
fait d'illustrer comment fonctionnait le
système parce que j'avais vu en fait son
parcours se construire des presque les
langes en gros quoi. Enfin c'est
vraiment parce que cette personne était
à laenne depuis la 3è de maternelle.
Donc même si moi je suis arrivé qu'en 6e
après avoir été dans le public, j'ai
j'ai rencontré toutes les sphères
sociales qu'il a formé, fabriqué et
cetera et j'ai vu quelqu'un de
complètement indifférent
euh à l'autre en fait s'installer dans
un système à à quelque prix que ce soit
et devenir ministre du simple fait de
son arrivisme et de son ambition. On
parle quand même quelqu'un de quelqu'un
qui qui fait qui fait des blagues sur
sur les sans domicile fixes et sur leurs
odeurs de façon récurrent témoin.
C'est Ouais, j'étais témoins direct.
Non, moi j'étais témoins direct. Des
personnes autour de moi évidemment enfin
tous ceux qui l'ont fréquenté sont
témoins. Il y a des témoignages écrits
quand vous allez sur ce blog dont parle
l'Express que je n'ai pas créé par
ailleurs. C'est ça qui est génial. Il le
titre en faisant croire que enfin en
donnant on a l'impression à ce couple le
4 je pense 4 novembre 2005 Bronco âgé de
15 ans créer un blog un Skyblog pour
noter les filles.
Vous avez attaqué en justice ?
Non non pas encore et je pense pas que
je vais le faire parce que je crois en
fait à circulation de l'information.
J'ai peut-être une conception je me pose
vraiment une question mais il y a
vraiment une question de me dire mais
est-ce que est-ce que c'est vraiment la
justice de dire ce qui est vrai ou faux
? Je pense je crois en fait à un moment
à la et j'ai j'ai une une assise sociale
aujourd'hui qui me permet peut-être de
pouvoir faire voir les mensonges et
manipulations sans avoir à m'appuyer sur
une autorité qui justement est là pour
servir ceux qui n'ont pas ces moyensl.
Euh mais ce blog là que je n'ai pas créé
donc c'est même leur scoop
extraordinaire hein qu'à 15 ans j'aurais
créé un un préfacebook en gros n'est pas
vrai. Ça aurait été participer après.
Mais bon dans ce blog qui est encore
accessib en ligne on voit des
commentaires de Gabriel euh qui qui
disait qui ironisait en fait sur les
lycées de périphéri sur le fait que la
la l'azacienne n'était plus tenue
socialement comme elle l'était qu'il n'y
avait plus assez en gros de personnes
qui étaient faisaient partie de la route
qui était et cetera. cette personne-là,
il s'agit pas de reprocher à quelqu'un
ce qu'il a dit à 15 ou à 15 ou 16 ans.
Voilà, c'est en fait la constance
du rapport qui s'est maintenu par la
suite parce que euh j'ai jamais alors ça
c'est aussi quelque chose de très
important dans ce livre en général, je
n'ai trahi l'intimité de personne. J'ai
jamais été ami de cette personne. C'est
j'ai pas utilisé l'accès que m'aurait
donné en confiance quelqu'un justement
du fait de lien personnel pour pour les
exposer. J'ai j'ai tenu vraiment à cette
éthique
très basique qui fasse qu'en fait tout
ce à quoi on a accès au j'ai accès et
que je révèle dans ce texte ne vient que
d'en fait d'un sorte de travail
d'enquête ou témoignage qui qui est
toujours respecté cette cette forme
d'intimité. Mais cette personneel a
continué en fait à non seulement faire
ça mais à porter ces politiques là. Et
c'est là en fait où il devient un objet
à dénoncer. c'est quand il brise une
grève de posti à 27 ans, alors qu'il n'a
toujours même pas créé de de permanence
euh euh parlementaire dans sa
circonscription parce qu'il a été élu
dans une circonscription qui a voté à 90
% pardon euh pour Macron au second tour
des élections. Donc qui lui a été donné
par son conjoint Stéphane Séjourné euh
qui était au comité d'investissure de de
En marche. Donc on lui donne la
meilleure circonscription, on lui donne
littéralement de façon à ce qu'il
s'impose là. Il en a rien à faire du
peuple lui qui a fait l'Ascienne
puissance po et cetera. Il sait très
bien qu'il ne doit rien à son rapport
avec la population. Il sait très bien
qu'en fait ces dispositifs sont
dispositifs d'intériisation qui
utilisent la forme démocratique pour
s'imposer dans l'espace politique. Mais
qu'est-ce qu'il fait ? Cette personne
très arrogante va parler des bobo
gauchistes pour parler des étudiants qui
qui occupent des universités pour se
battre contre une réforme complètement
unique. Il va attaquer les chemineaux.
il va briser une grève de postier en
distribuant lui-même le courrier dans au
sein de sa circonscription euh postier
qui se battait pour la défense du
service public et ainsi de suite. En
fait, il va s'installer dans une dans
une politique au service des intérêts de
ceux qui l'ont propulsé qui va permettre
à moi de faire ce texte qui va tenter
d'expliquer
comment ça se fait que des personnes
comme ça arrivent au pouvoir et
expliquer en fait les racines pour
permettre de comprendre aux Français de
comprendre en fait comment en fait dans
l'entreo du petit Paris dès les plus
jeune âge on va conformer des gens pour
les amener à défendre des idées qui qui
vont être au détriment du collectif. Et
donc Gabriel encore une fois
Gabriel,
il prend cher. C'est pas c'est mais mais
c'est pas lui le sujet. Je m' je m'en
fiche complètement en fait. C'est c'est
juste qu'il va me permettre d'exposer
des choses et je crois que
d'un moment que ces personnesl font le
choix de rentrer en politique et cetera,
ils acceptent en retour le fait qu'on
expose les raisons de leur engagement et
cetera et qu'on et qu'on le et et et
qu'on les critique à cet avenant. Moi,
je le critique pas. J'essaie juste
d'exposer factuellement euh ce qu'il est
pour montrer en fait à travers lui
comment se fabrique dans le système de
propagande en fait massif et de petit
communage de de combinaison en fait de
facteurs. Euh les ministres
d'aujourd'hui qui ne vont rien
représenter et qui ne vont faire que
porter des intérêts. Un dernier mot sur
Mimi Marchand, l'ouvrage dont je vous
parlais en fait j'ai on n'est pas arrivé
au bout du rusement. Pourquoi est-ce que
Mimi en fait est un cet ouvrage est un
scandale ? parce qu'il donne
l'impression au lecteur et c'est en fait
c'est ce qui va permettre de comprendre
à quel point la fabrique d'information
est viciée dans ce pays. Il donne
l'impression aux lecteurs euh que c'est
marchand donc qui a permis à Emmanuel
Macron de rentrer dans l'espace public,
d'être propulsé et de faire toutes ces
une et cetera et donc avec une notoriété
de papier glacé complètement artificiel
euh de s'imposer aux français pour après
évidemment s'effondrer comme une star de
téléréalité s'effondre rien parce que à
semaine X vous l'aimez à x + 1 bah vous
rendez compte qu'en fait parce que c'est
complètement superficiel.
Et ben Mimi ce que raconte pas Mimi,
c'est que qui est le propriétaire de
Paris Match et compagnie donc de tous
ces appareils de pouvoir qui sont mis en
place pour mis en branle pardon pour
défendre Emmanuel Macron. Bah c'est
Arnaud Lagarder et pourquoi est-ce qu'il
raconte pas que c'est évidemment Arnaud
Lagarder et son homme de main Ramzi
Kiroun qui était conseiller de Macron en
communication qui ont fait cette
opération de communication en s'appuyant
sur les outils que leur fournissait
Xavier et notamment cette Paparadzi mais
qui évidemment pas capable enfin c'est
Parad qui est pas capable d'imposer une
une à Paris match. Enfin, voyez bien,
c'est pas la pauvre mini marchand pour
qui fait lever de la victoire dans le
bureau de l'Élysée quelques semaines
après l'élection de Macron. C'est pas
elle qui a ce pouvoir là, c'est
évidemment les propriétaire de ces
médias qui font la ligne éditoriale de
ces médias. Pourquoi ils le disent pas ?
Parce que l'ouvrage est publié chez
Grasset et Grasset appartient à qui ? À
Hchette. Et Hchette appartient à qui ? À
la Gardèire. Et donc vous avez des
pseudos journaux enfin soit médias soit
livres d'investigation qui sont censés
vous donner la vérité qui font du
scandale exactement avec la fermé et qui
en fait servent à masquer
et à vous et en fait à cramer un un
clamp. Donc on se débarrasse de mis
marchand on met quelqu'un d'autre à la
place et entre-temps là-haut tout va
bien.
On va passer aux questions internet.
Euh quel intellectuel quels sont les
intellectuels qui ont grâce à vos yeux ?
En France aujourd'hui, il y a évidemment
Tod, Emmanuel Todd, qui est
qui a qui a compris ce qui était la
Macronie sans l'avoir fréquenter,
contrairement à moi, mais par
intelligence en fait et qui qui a une
critique très similaire à la mienne qui
est fascinante. Il faut vraiment
l'écouter sur sur Macron parce qu'il on
dit à peu près la même chose quoi. Et et
avec une lui une acuté systémique assez
assez importante des personnes comme
Lordon.
Après, encore une fois, l'écosystème
intellectuel français s'est effondré
parce que à force de mettre en place
politique publiques, l'argent dans la
recherche,
les grandes écoles, l'université,
l'absence de diversité sociale provoque
en fait des ces fondaments. Quand vous
êtes dans des euh, il y a une anecdote
par exemple de Nioliven qui est un des
hommes de lige comme ça de des médias et
cetera. Euh trois de ses enfants ont
fait normal
ou une grande enfin voyez c'estàdire
qu'à un moment je veux dire je crois au
patrimoine génétique mais à un moment je
crois aussi au fait que ces ces écoles
n'ont plus qu'une qu'une fonction c'est
de reproduire
% du milieu socioculturel donc à un
moment il faut quand même s'interroger
sur le fait ces écoles ne font plus
rayonner
la France pourquoi parce qu'elles
servent à reproduire les positions
acquises et non plus à amener les vrais
plus grands talents, les vrais meilleurs
talents du pays à à exercer des
fonctions. Et donc à un momentù le
vivier s'assèche, bah évidemment vous
retrouvez sans sans sans puissance. Et
alors quand évidemment derrière vous
avez tous les systèmes de médiocrisation
de l'espace éditorial, médiatique et
cetera, bah il y a un affaisement de
l'exigence qui fait que que ce pays est
devenu ce qu'il est. C'est-à-dire que
plus personne ne s'exige parce que
chacun est dans des compromissions
successives et donc évidemment chacun
accepte de fermer l'œil sur
l'insuffisance de l'autre, de jouer des
réseaux de copinage et cetera. Bah
évidemment, elle a rien à la fin il ne
reste plus rien.
Autre question, le fait que Niel et des
parts dans Media Part, est-ce que ça
vous pose problème ? Moi ce qui me pose
problème c'est que Media part n'est
toujours pas racheté ses ses pars qui
sont minoritaires, hein, très
minoritaires. Et que au contraire de
l'avoir fait, quand Fabrice Arfi
interrogé par le service Check News de
Libération pour dire est-ce queel est
actionnaire de Méia Part, il dit non, on
peut pas dire ça. Puis après il dit
qu'en fait si enfin il factuellement
c'est le cas et il dit à la fin il dit
oui donc on vous voyez en fait c'est
insignifiant dans ce cas-là pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils ne sont pas débarrassés de
ces scories et pourquoi ils ne le font
pas qu'est-ce qui fait que ces
personnes-là et ben j'explique dans le
livre en fait que ça fait partie d'un
écosystème général c'est pas queelle en
fait c'est que l'écosystème de Mediapart
s'intègre de façon assez logique dans
cette idéologie
auquel ils ont finalement cru on a vu
que le traitement de médiia par de
Macron campagne il y avait d'un côté le
c'était intéressant il y a d'un côté
un travail d'enquête très important de
grande valeur. à faire benala c'est
c'est le monde mais mais il y a eu toute
une série d'enquêtes sur colère sur les
services sur l'aéroport de Paris et
cetera sauf que l'éditorialisation
n'avait rien à voir avec c'estàdire que
éditorialement parlant il y avait une
complaisance extraordinaire qu'on a vu
notamment dans les entretiens que Macron
a donné à Mediaapart pendant la campagne
entre deux tours où on se rendait compte
qu'il ne tirait pas du tout les
conclusions de ce qu'il de de ce qu'il
décrivait et donc dans cette c cet yatus
ahurissant on bah on commence on
comprend que au-delà de la question de
euh enfin que le journalisme d'enquête,
d'investigation n'est rien sans une
intelligence derrière qui permette en
fait d'en faire produire des effets
politique. Si vous dites ils sont
complètement corrompus et que vous en
tirez pas de conséquences,
vous voyez, il y a il y a une vous créez
l'impuissance, vous créez une
frustration, vous faites vendre, vous
fabriquez du scandale mais du scandale
qui va se recycler, qui va vous
permettre en fait de maintenir le
système tel qu'il est. Il y a un
problème de système aujourd'hui en
France, c'est pas en exposant tel ou tel
pan, il faut remettre en question de
façon générale le système oligarchique
de ce pays. Il y a pas il y a pas de
façon de s'en sortir autrement.
Aujourd'hui, on ne peut pas arriver à
présidence de la 5e République et
j'envoie énormément à des personnes
comme Ruffin, Boulot et cetera de se
laisser prendre dans ses ambitions en
fait euh politiques. Donc on voit bien
qu'ils essayent de masquer et cetera,
mais quand Ruffin fait son texte dans
lequel il se met en parallèle avec
Macron sur sur 300 pages et qu'à deux
moments, il dit "Ah, c'est difficile de
résister à la la question
présidentielle, mais il faut que je
résiste mais je sais pas quoi."
Il y a dès le moment que vous vous
faites avoir ou que vous rentrez dans ce
rapport de vanité dans lequel vous dites
que moi je pourrais faire mieux que
Emmanuel Mac, vous comprenez rien.
Enfin, vous vous désactivez en fait,
vous aspirez cette énergie
révolutionnaire ou de rupture profonde
que vous avez mené toute votre vie parce
que Ruffin c'est quelqu'un d'un courage
extrême, admirable. Mais dès le moment
que vous vous laissez prendre par cette
sorte de petite cour qui va vous faire
croire, exactement comme elle a fait
avec Emmanuel Macron, qu'en fait vous
vous êtes particulier, que je sais pas
quoi et qu'en tant qu'individu vous pour
changer, personne en tant qu'individu ne
peut changer ce système de l'intérieur
parce que pour arriver à cette place-là,
vous allez devoir faire des collègues de
fond, vous allez devoir vous insérer
dans le petit Paris, vous allez devoir
en fait vous appuyer sur les dispositifs
pour démocratiquement c'est impossible
de s'exfiltrer de tout ça. Soit vous
vous êtes sincère et vous proposez un
vrai rupture systémique avec un retour à
un régime parlementaire qui soit
représentatif et cetera, soit vous êtes
en train de vous laisser avoir par une
catastrophante qui ne peut aller nulle
part.
Est-ce que vous avez lu euh les pinçons
Charlot ?
Oui.
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ? Bah, le
dernier ouvrage était pas intéressant
parce qu'il est c'est une ressuscée de
de de données qui sont de de notoriété
publique. Je pense qu'il a
idéologiquement en gros en terme de de
stratégie euh pour nous c'est un en tant
que ceux qui veulent changer le système
c'est toujours intéressant d'avoir mais
c'est pas intellectuellement quelque
chose intéressant. Par contre leur
travail sur long terme est
extraordinaire. C'est rien mais ça dit
quelque chose aussi qu' il soit si
singulier dans l'espace public. C'estàd
le fait d'interroger les classes
dominantes soit vu comme quelque chose
d'exceptionnel. Enfin, je suis désolé si
la sociologie sert à quelque chose,
c'est pas pour enfin c'est d'abord pour
servir de contrepouvoir et aller
chercher ces personnes-là. Enfin, c'est
donc ça me sidère en fait que que ces
personnes-là qui sont soient si isolées
en fait dans notre dans notre champ
intellectuel. Donc pardon hein d'avoir
fait cette remarque mais de façon
générale, c'est de la même façon quand
je reproche à boulot d'avoir un
conseiller en communication qui échange
avec les gilets jaunes en son nom.
Enfin, je veux dire euh c'est si
j'arrête de ma critique euh dès le
moment que ça touche mes alliés, je suis
en train de reproduire ce que je
dénonce, quoi. Donc je suis obligé
d'avoir cette sincérité. Quitte à ce que
ça soit désagréable pour eux, mais
quitte aussi derrière à ce qu'ils disent
"Merde, en fait, faut peut-être faut
peut-être que j'arrête d'agir comme ça
et tant pis si moi du coup je me
retrouve un peu de côté par rapport à
eux." C'est pas le sujet. La question
c'est un moment, il faut avoir cette
exigence jusqu'au bout. Donc désolé
François si je t'ai vexé quand j'ai dit
ça rouin parce que visiblement ça
provoquait beaucoup de remou mais c'est
essentiel, c'est essentiel de mettre des
limites et de dire c'est pas ça la
solution, c'est pas par là. Si on va
dans cette direction-là, on s'effondre.
Comment comprenez-vous l'affaire Benala
?
Benala, c'est quelqu'un qui a aucun
appui dans l'espace élitaire français.
C'est que c'est un c'est un c'est un un
arabe qui a pas fait de grandes études
pour le dire dans les termes de l'élite
bourgeoise. Donc c'est quelqu'un qui est
qui a vocation à être ostracisé dans
l'espace social parisien euh qui réussit
à avoir un pouvoir que du coup les
autres considèrent comme complètement
scandaleux et délirant qui va donc se
fabriquer beaucoup d'ennemis de ce fait
et qui à un moment va se faire sortir et
il va se faire sortir par Arian de
Chemin qui va faire cet article où il va
démontrer que c'est lui sans d'ailleurs
remercier le journaliste qui avait filmé
cette chose Tarabouaf enfin en le
mettant complètement de côté en
s'appropriant complètement le scoop
parce qu'elle même est dans une logique
de concurrence
au sein de cette élite parisienne de
distinction et Arien chemin euh va le
faire parce qu'Arien chemin croit et
alors c'est peut-être c'est une seule
date de l'ordre au sens fort du terme
c'estàd c'est quelqu'un qui croit
absolument dans le système tel qu'il
existe et donc il ne supporte pas les
dérives système quel qu'elle soit parce
qu'elle croit qu'elle mais pas parce que
parce qu'elle croit qu'elle menace ce
système. Donc quelqu'un comme Benala qui
abuse de ses fonctions et qui va
tabasser un fonctionnaire c'est
quelqu'un qu'il faut sortir un pardon un
citoyen. quelqu'un qu'il faut faire
sortir parce qu'elle a cette croyance
qui est meilleure que tout ce que j'ai
décrit jusqu'ici qui sont des gens qui
ne croient qu'en leurs intérêts. Elle
elle a une croyance quand même quelque
part. C'est une croyance à mon sens
naïve parce qu'elle participe en fait au
renouvellement du système mais qui
produit des effets qui produit des
effets parce que du coup elle a
l'opignâreté d'aller sortir de faire
sortir l'information et comme en fait
cette personne-là n'est pas intégrée
dans dans le petit Paris enfin ou pas
dans ce petit paris je décris dans
d'autres réseaux protomafieux et cetera
mais qui sont assez secondaires par
rapport à ce que j'ai décris et bien
évidemment on peut le sortir et on se
dit pas que ça va avoir les conséquences
que ça et la seule raison pour laquelle
il y a eu ces conséquences là c'est pas
pas parce que le monde ou quoi que ce
soit c'est parce Macron décide de
s'accrocher. Si Macron s'était pas
accroché, le truc serait arrêté au bout
d'une semaine, on en parlerait plus. Et
donc enfin, on en fait une sorte de
monument de journalisme depuis
maintenant. On parle des passeports
diplomatiques et des choses en fait qui
sont complètement insignifiantes, qui
qui ne nous apprennent plus rien parce
qu'on a l'impression qu'on est encore en
train de faire quelque chose de
subversif. Euh dans les faits, ce qu'il
y a de surversif, c'est ce que Macron
crée dans cette attache à cet homme-là,
qu'il est incapable incapable de lâcher.
Mais
sur les passeports diplomatiques, ça
nous apprend quand même beaucoup de
choses. Le le fait que on lâche des
passeports diplomatiques comme ça, le
fait qu'il garde un téléphone chiffré,
vous êtes conseillé, bah vous êtes
conseillé de l'Élysée, vous avez
passeport diplomatique. Pardonnez-moi,
je vois pas le problème. Enfin, c'est
c'est pas ça. C'est pas un enjeu
journalistique ça.
Revenez à ce que je suis en train de
vous décrire, les centaines de millions
d' même la corruption de Benala, les
contrats à quelques centaines milli
d'euros plus d'un million, c'est rien en
comparaison à ce qu'on est en train de
décrire. Ça c'est la corruption banale.
C'est la corruption qui en fait que le
système dont le système peut se défaire.
Les juges d'instruction sont là pour ça,
pas pour s'attaquer au aux affaires à
plusieurs milliards. Uramine 1,8
milliard d'euros. Où est cet argent de
l'argent public ? 1,8 milliards d'euros.
4000 emplois supprimés. Où est cette les
j d'instruction sont dessus depuis 10
ans. Est-ce qu'il y a une personne qui a
été détenu ? Pas une seule personne.
Donc vous parlez de Benalad cette
corruption de vulgaire, vous voyez c'est
un c'est vraiment c'est le type qui
abuse. Voyez évidemment que c'est
important de la sanctionner juste là
pour ça mais je veux dire c'est les
enjeux ne sont pas là. Les enjeux ne
sont pas et alors quand et quand médiia
part tente d'en faire une affaire d'état
il mente. C'est pas une affaire d'État.
C'est pas une affaire d'état. C'est une
affaire de corruption individuelle.
C'est la les affaires d'état, c'est les
grosses affaires sur lesquelles Martin
Orange et d'autres jour Médiia par
travaillent d'ailleurs. C'est et c'est
des affaires sur lesquelles on n'arrive
pas à sanctionner les personnes.
Vous votez ? Vous croyez au vote ?
Non, je vote plus. Euh et c'est drôle
parce que
même pas blanc.
Euh j'ai peut-être voté blanc mais je
reprochais énormément à mes parents de
pas voter, mais vraiment énormément.
J'ai dit "Mais vous avez fuite des
dictatures et vous votez pas ?" Enfin,
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui Et euh et en
fait, j'ai fini par j'ai fini par la
première fois que ça m'est devenu
difficile, c'était en 2012, donc quand
j'avais fait la campagne de François
Hollande et que je savais que je pouvais
pas voter pour François Hollande en
ayant vu ce que j'avais vu. Je pouvais
pas et j'ai mis une demi-heure dans mon
dans mon isoloir vraiment je suis sorti
de l'isoloire avec mes Je disais va joli
Poutou Poutou et va jolie et Poutou
voyez pourquoi Poutou c'est la parce que
Poutou est un ouvrier et qu'à un moment
cette parole doit être portée en espace
politique. C'est pas une question de
compétence, c'est pas une question de le
faire présent et cetera. C'est un moment
où il faut rendre la parole à quand même
un/ers de la population française. Donc
j'étais là, j'hésitais entre
l'anticorruption, je sais pas quoi et à
un moment et puis voilà. Après, je pense
que j'ai voté blanc finalement et j'ai
pas eu j'ai pas voté au législative. Je
me suis présenté au législative en 2017
avec la France insoumise. Il y a eu 75 %
d'abstention dans ma circonscription et
et je peux vous dire que je les
comprenais
et je les comprenais. C'est
ta faute mec, tu as pas fait campagne
correctement. C'était impossible de
faire campagne.
Comment la la dans ces espaces-là ?
J'étais j'étais allé volontairement dans
une circonscription, on m'avait proposé
d'aller à Saint-Denis où en gros
Mélenchon avait fait 50 %. Euh donc
enfin il était
Oui. Que je devenais député. Enfin, il
fallait lutter contre le député
communiste qui a été élu depuis Stéphane
Peu mais bon a priorié. et j'ai décidé
d'aller à Cliché sous-bois au fin fond
du 93 Montfermeil là où les misérables
de Victor Hugo mais aussi Laurenci et
cetera qui a une circonstion on a très
peu de chance et et qui est une sorte de
mini France et j'ai vu la la désérance
et la la destruction de la société quoi.
Les gens ne se parlent plus c'est et là
où en fait les gens se parlaient le plus
faisaient le plus société cliché sous
bois parce qu'il y a tellement plus rien
que les gens ont fini par reconstruire
en fait un village. Reconstruire un
village mais en mode moyen-âge quoi.
C'est-à-dire vraiment où en gros vous
pour faire les courses, il y a des parce
que les ascenseurs sont tous pétés, il y
a des il y a des systèmes de pouli de
enfin vous voyez vous c'est et et du
coup il y a il y a une chaleur humaine
extrêmement forte, il y a le marché des
saveurs et cetera mais dès que vous
sortez de là, vous parliez à quelqu'un
dans le marché et vous saviez que cette
personne allait parler à personne
derrière. Donc vous passiez une
demi-heure pour lui expliquer je sais
pas quoi. Vous disiez bon, j'ai
peut-être convaincu, mais vous saviez
qu'en fait derrière il y aura aucun
effet parce qu'il y a une dépolitisation
absolue et comme il y a pas de médias,
les médias qui restent, c'est euh ça
c'est un truc aussi j'ai découvert
crépuscule, personne en parle en France,
en Norvège le principal média euh
journal mais Norvégien en parle et je
vais du coup je vais regarder qu'est-ce
que c'est que ce média norvégien pour
savoir est-ce que c'est important,
est-ce que c'est juste un blog et la con
enfin avant de dire à Norvège en parle,
je vais quand même vérifier, je vois que
c'est le principal. Surtout qu'il y a
une diffusion de 300000 exemplaires
quotidiens et une rédaction de 750
personnes. C'est c'est autant que le
monde. Il y a 5 millions de personnes en
Norvège.
Je crois que leur rédaction c'est 900
journalistes.
Au monde, c'est 400. 400.
Non, mais chez les Norvégiens.
Euh oui, enfin je sais non, j'avais cru
750 mais peut-être. Enfin, voyez, c'est
c'estd que la presse aujourd'hui n'est
ne joue plus sa fonction en France. Et
donc pendant les présidentielles vous
tenez encore grâce à BFM, grâce à je
sais pas quoi Nana. au moment des
législatives encore en plus dans dans
des espaces où il y a aucune média
locale et cetera, vous avez beau faire
ce que vous pouvez faire en fait du coup
qu'est-ce qui va se passer ? Il y a une
reproduction des votes enfin tel quel
présidentielle quoi. C'estàd qu'il y a
le candidat en marche est élu sans faire
campagne mais vraiment sans faire
campagne.
Autre question internet. Faut-il venir
de l'élite pour maîtriser ses codes et
pouvoir ainsi la critiquer et la
renverser ?
Non, il faut qu'il y ait des gens de
l'élite qui qui transmettent leurs
connaissances de l'intérieur. C'est ce
que je fais. Moi, je je rends des armes
en fait. Donc avec ce que je vous écris,
je vous lis et ce travail que j'essaie
de faire, je donne à chacun la
possibilité de et au lieu de participer
au marché de l'information, de rester
captif et de parce que par exemple sur
Gabriel, je reviens là-dessus, qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce que quelqu'un de normal
entre guillemets au sein de cette élite
parisienne aurait fait ? Il aurait
commencé à balancer euh anonymement à la
presse, ce qui vous permet de vous faire
bien voir des journalistes parce que
vous leur donnez matière à leur et en
retour, ça vous permet de démonter un
peu dégueulassement. C'est ce qu'on a
fait pour l'article de l'express et
cetera. Et à un moment, ça aussi c'était
une façon pour moi de rompre avec ce
système là, dire mais non moi enfin il
faut y aller, il faut si on y va, c'est
parce qu'on croit en ce enfin il faut il
faut prendre le risque assumer ce qui va
me valoir. On va me dire "Ah oui mais
c'est parce qu'il t'a piqué ta comping
quand tu as 15 ans ou je sais pas quoi.
Enfin je m'en fous complètement.
L'important mais c'est pas vrai. Mais
l'important c'est que c'est que c'est
que c'est de donner des outils de pensée
aux gens qui n'ont pas forcément eu
accès à ces espaces là ou j'ai accès et
après que chacun fasse ce qu'il veut
avec et ce qu'il peut et que lui-même
réfléchisse. C'est pareil quand vous
dites qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire ? On me
possède cette c'est pas à moi de donner
la réponse. Sinon, encore une fois, je
suis en train de reproduire. Moi, je
crois qu'il faut une rupture
fondamentale, mais c'est à chacun avec
l'information
euh que que j'aurais transmise de se
décider, de vérifier ce que j'écrit,
d'aller compléter avec d'autres sources
et cetera, de se faire sa conscience
politique et à partir de là de
s'affirmer.
Comment allez-vous éviter le
branchobashing pour décrédibiliser votre
prop ? Je vais pas l'éviter et c'est
très bien. Enfin, il y a pas de il y a
pas de problème. Le plus, ils le font.
L'article de Express déjà c'était
tellement grossier, c'était génial.
Enfin, il confirme ce que j'aiécrit.
Enfin, je veux dire à un moment je
cherche
était prévenu avant que ça allait
sortir.
Alors, c'est incroyable un message privé
d'un compte sur sur Twitter qui me dit
"Vous avez été balancé par les RG, donc
c'est visiblement pas quelqu'un de la
DGSI parce que sinon il saurait que ça
s'appelle plus les RG". Euh et euh on
sait que il y a il y a un article qui va
sortir dans dans l'Express sur vous, un
portrait et il va raconter que vous
étiez euh que vous hébergez Maxime
Licocol comme si j'avais hébergé euh
Carlos quoi. Et euh et euh avec plein de
salutures et cetera et euh
et je lui dis "Mais d'accord mais vous
êtes qui ?" et cetera. Je dis "Mais je
peux pas vous dire mais on se croisera
peut-être à acte 5 et cetera." Puis il
désactive son compte. Évidemment, j'ai
fait toutes les capture écran et je l'ai
révélé publiquement. C'était 4 jours
avant la publication article, personne
savait. Et moi encore, je croyais encore
à la naïveté hein, à la sincérité des
journalistes. Euh Benoît Fchner et
compagnie qui sont quelqu'un des
personnes en fait d'une pauvre humanité,
je pense malheureusement et j'ai une
grande tristesse pour eux pour ce qu'ils
ont fait. Je les appelle et je leur dis
"Mais attendez, on m'écrit ça, c'est que
c'est qu'est-ce qui c'est quoi cette
histoire quoi ?" Et là en fait, il
rentre dans une sorte de panique de dire
"Mais c'est quoi ? C'est qui la taupe ?"
Je sais pas quoi. N et il cherche à
savoir parce que personne ne savait
qu'on faisait un portrait de moi et euh
et voilà. Et en effet 3 jours après mis
en une de site de Express en accessible
à tout le monde, ce qui est assez rare
pour ce genre de portrait.
À quoi joue Ran Branco, le radical chic
R Branco et cetera avec à peu près une
erreur par ligne, quelques mensonges
parfois enfin et même ce qui est génial
c'est que les erreurs parfois à mon en
ma faveur c'est qu'il se trompent en
surestimant mon score législatif,
c'est quand même pas compliqué de
retrouver un score législatif. Donc je
je du coup je leur fais un mail où je
leur liste l'ensemble des erreurs faites
mais vraiment un truc enfin du coup qui
fait deux pages parce qu'il y a vraiment
une erreur par page mais délirant hein
et euh et toujours évidemment la plupart
du temps pouré et ils ont corrigé une
seule erreur une seule celle du score
législatif parce qu'elle était en ma
faveur. Toutes les autres sont passées à
la trappe. C'est quand même Et là j'ai
dit j'ai envoyé un texto à ce Benoît
Fchner. Je dit euh
joli crachat, merci merci de signer
votre geste parce que évidemment c'était
c'était vraiment une façon de me cracher
au visage.
Ils attaquent pour justice.
À quoi ? Bon la médiocrité quand elle
s'expose comme ça, quel intérêt ? Encore
une fois, je suis pas dans une
stratégie, je l'étais hein, encore une
fois comme je vous l'ai dit, j'ai
accumulé tout ce capital symbolique et
cetera. J'ai je suis plus dans ces
stratégies distinction. dans le regard.
Aujourd'hui, j'ai trouvé encore une fois
avec les gilets jaunes un rapport à
l'autre euh qui a une capacité à porter
une parole sans dépendre de ses réseaux
d'intérêt, de services et cetera. Euh
une une une liberté qui qui me permet
d'en avoir strictement rien à carré
puisque'au final ils disent rien de que
j'ai créé ou pas ce Skyblog, même si
c'était vrai. Enfin, tout le monde s'en
fiche, voyez. Enfin, qu'est-ce que qu'
ils peuvent y aller ? Moi j'ai pas ça ça
m'indiffère.
C'est une commande à votre avis ? Je
sais pas, je sais pas, ça m'intéresse
pas, c'est leur problème. Et euh ce qui
est sûr, c'est qu'évidemment ça
intervient après que j'ai révéler
comment ces personnes-là s'étaient
complètement compromises pendant
l'élection de Macron, enfin pour
favoriser l'élection de Macron.
Vous v vous alors question internet,
vous vivez de quoi aujourd'hui ?
Je suis RSA.
Euh j'ai la chance d'avoir une famille
qui m'aide et qui m'a aidé à trouver un
lieu où rester quelques mois encore. Euh
et je redémarré hein, j'ai pas de j'ai
pas d'inquiétude particulière mais je
trouve que ça me donne une force très
forte. C'estd que j'ai vraiment rien à
perdre. J'ai vraiment
euh j'ai vraiment vu à quel point ce
il y a évidemment ça ça arrive hein des
histoire personnelles, familial et
cetera qui ont fait qu'il y a une une
difficulté très grande qui m'ont amené à
cette situation mais aussi surtout ce
mur en fait que provoquait système qui
dès le moment que vous acceptiez pas euh
l'échange de service et cetera vous vous
écrasait complètement. Et donc j'ai
accepté le fait de pas je gagnais
jusqu'à 8000 € par mois quand j'assurais
à temps plein la défense de Wikileage.
C'est que j'étais dans un institut de
recherche au Luxembourg. J'ai tenu 4
mois au Luxembourg.
Je conseille quelconque personne qui a
un rapport à l'altérité
euh et euh et euh et au politique ne ne
tient pas plus et quiconque vit plus
longtemps Luxembourg devrait
s'interroger. qui ne soit pas
luxembourgeois, on est là-dedans. C'est
devenu un espace monstrueux socialement
et c'est évidemment une concentration de
richesse délirante
de de fuite de
de richesse qui nous appartiennent à
tous et qui en même temps construit un
système de dépendance où vous avez
toutes les personnes qui ont souffert de
la désindustrialisation massive des
années 80 autour dans le bassin minier
Laurin et compagnie qui sont obligés
d'aller chercher les miettes au
Luxembourg pour survivre et faire des
allers-retours dans les embouteillages
entre les Maserati et les et les et
compagnie pour donc j'avais un une
euh extrêmement agréable hein, mais en
même temps extrêmement violente avec
Wikileak parce que c'était pas du tout
enfin évidemment la source de mon
désengagement de ce système là c'est
Wikileak. C'est la découverte. Je peux
vous dire j'ai eu je suis arrivé le
curtané avec les gilets jaunes he parce
que s'il y en a un qui s'est fait
diffamer traité de violeur d'antisémite
et cetera et c'est aussi avec lui que
j'ai appris qu'il fallait un moment
lâcher prise dire que enfin il y a pas
eu un instant où jeange n'a pas été
considéré comme l'antéchrist que ce soit
parce qu'il était agent du FSB violeur
et cetera et les campagnes se
succédaient à chaque fois qu'on
finissait après des années de la beur
par démontrer que c'était faux personne
s'excusait pas un journaliste, pas un
pas une personne qui relayait ces
articles disait "Mais en fait merde on a
quand même failli vous détruire votre
parce qu'on participait inconsciemment à
des stratégies de pouvoir euh visant à
vous détruire très clairement. Et euh
donc je suis arrivé là donc après avoir
travaillé avec le Nieu et compagnie à un
moment avec une capacité à dire mais bon
enfin peut-être que l'essentiel est
ailleurs et et j'avais des réserves.
J'ai un peu à peu consommé ces réserves
là et je me suis retrouvé là un peu à
l'osite voilà limite de la rupture avec
un capital symbolique très important
parce que je continue à défendre Juliane
et Wikileak aller le voir régulièrement.
Euh je défends des personnes
gratuitement en tant qu'avocat parce que
je considère par ailleurs que
l'avocature devrait être un un service
public. Il n'y a aucune raison qu'on
puisse favoriser certaines personnes
parce qu'ils sont capables de se payer
des avocats au détriment d'autres.
Enfin, c'est un truc tellement délirant
pour moi et contradictoire. Et voilà. Et
peu à peu ça va. J'ai fait je fais
parfois quelques enquêtes pour mon
diplomatique et euh
et euh et j'ai probablement peut-être
j'ai eu quelques avaloirs pour les deux
textes contre Macron et combien
euh pour contre Macron, j'ai pas eu
d'avaloir parce que j'ai fait avec un un
type génial, un type de 27 ans qui je
pense a touché un PQU, je sais pas si un
héritage, je sais pas quoi et au lieu de
comme tout le monde s'acheter un appart
ou je sais pas quoi, décider de faire
une maison d'édition et à tel seul avoir
le courage d'éditer contre Macron.
Johann bah je le laisse aller sur le
site des éditions divergence vous
verrez. Et qui ce courage extraordinaire
alors que toutes les grandes maisons
parce que j'ai dit j'ai été publié chez
FA et compagnie au pas parce queil y
avait un étouffire extraordinaire
pendant la première année de la
Macronie. On s'est dit bon ben on y va
banco mise en place de 400 exemplaires
rien. On en est à 8000 vendu. Enfin
c'est un énorme succès pour pour un
ouvrage de cet ordre là sorti avec aucun
moyen. Aucune presse. Aucune presse
sinon su radio une fois évidemment.
Euh et euh et voilà. ça me donnait, je
sais pas, peut-être 4000 € qui qui v me
permettre de de peut-être payer mon
loyer, de sortir de euh de l'ornière et
et pour pour ce texte.
Donc
euh euh
faut le montrer à la caméra. La caméra,
c'est là hein. Euh crépuscule. dont
c'est vraiment des gens qui ont pris
énormément de risque pour enfin je suis
tellement fier d'eux et de enfin
vraiment cet objet m'a vraiment m'ému
énormément parce que parce qu'on
s'expose énormément en le faisant et je
pense qu'on a tous conscience qu'on
qu'on aura besoin d'une bascule
justement pour pour pour en tirer et et
pour ce texte là ils ont comme il y a
une grosse mise en place je vais avoir
droit à 9000 € de
d'avaloir ce qui ce qui voilà va me
permettre de tenir d'ici la fin de
l'année
et avec cette idée que pour ceux qui
peuvent pas se le payer. Du coup, on a
fait attention, on a fait une couverture
bosselée, on a mis des on a mis il y a
un anonyme parce qu'il y a beaucoup
d'anonymes qui m'ont envoyé des versions
corrigées, qui m'ont envoyé des dessins,
qui m'ont envoyé des c'était ça c'était
magnifique. Enfin, il y avait un vrai
mouvement autour du texte de
réappropriation et cetera. pour ceux qui
peuvent pas le seul payer, il est en
ligne quoi. Et contre Macron aussi est
en ligne. C'est que n'importe qui peut
peut y avoir accès et qui veut l'acheter
combien
peut l'acheter. C'est un peu cher. C'est
c'est le comme on a on s'est dit en fait
il faut qu'on en fasse un objet donc on
l'a mis à 19 € ce qui est ce qui est pas
évident mais ceux qui l'auront auront
auront quelque chose qui
Moi, j'ai de la chance. Je l'ai je l'ai
lu en avant-première.
Ouais. En PDF. Alors, c'est un des
Alors, ça aussi c'est un autre chose.
Euh euh
on l'a pas envoyé pour l'instant. Euh
contrairement à Ruffa, on l'a vraiment
pas fait. Là c'est c'est je sais très
bien que c'est une polémique rigolote
ça. Aucun aucun intérêt. Mais mais et au
point moi j'ai dit à l'éditeur, je sais
pas si ça fait, j'aurais dit mais si
journalistes veulent le bouquin qu'
l'achète quoi. Parce que les services
press où on les envoie à un moment ça
suffit quoi. Enfin il faut
Donc si tu me laisses terminer ma phrase
donc moi je l'ai lu, je l'ai lu cette
nuit et il faut l'acheter hein. C'est
c'est une étude.
Ah le livre ouais. Ou le lire le lire.
Mais il faut en parler parce que même si
on est pas d'accord, on peut reprocher
ou quoi que ce soit. Euh j'ai trouvé ça
très bien écrit. Euh euh
vraiment vraiment pour que je le lise
d'une traite,
c'est que ça valait le coup hein. Autre
question d'internet. Pour résoudre la
crise démocratique, on commence par quoi
? Alors on achète le livre. Bah, on
s'informe et on se rebelle et on va on
va samedi sur les chambres.
Euh, la France insoumise a-t-elle un
fonctionnement démocratique ?
Non, et je pense pas qu'elle prétend de
l'avir. Je pense que Mélenchon a bien
conscience qu'il doit rentrer dans une
verticale du pouvoir très forte pour
pouvoir s'imposer au système,
éventuellement de changer. Moi, je suis
pas d'accord forcément avec la stratégie
qui est suivie. C'est pour ça que j'ai
pris mes distances. Euh j'ai beaucoup
d'estime pour lui. Euh enfin c'est
quelqu'un qui a toujours été respectueux
à mon égard et et qui m'a donné une
chance extraordinaire qui était de nous
présenter à à à ces élections parce que
c'était une aventure humaine magnifique.
En fait, on enfin le résultat était pas
était vraiment pas le l'enjeu et euh et
je pense que tous ceux qui ont participé
vous le diront d'ailleurs. Enfin,
c'était vraiment un truc incroyable et
euh et voilà. Donc moi, je suis pas
d'accord avec sa stratégie. Moi je pense
qu'il faut aller sur il aurait dû
beaucoup plus tôt soutenir le gilet
jaune, ce qu'il a pas fait. il a eu peur
comme tous ceux qui sont intégrés au
système, c'est naturel. Euh je pense
qu'il aurait fallu être en rupture
beaucoup plus tôt et voilà, maintenant
il il joue sa partition quoi. Enfin,
est-ce que est-ce qu'il aura raison ou
est-ce que c'est moi qui aurais eu
raison ? On verra, on verra avec le
temps. Mais euh
question d'internet, comment pourrait-on
se débarrasser de cette caste très
puissante ?
Euh, les Champs.
Les quoi ?
Les Champs.
Les Champ ? Ouais, les Champs éélysées
samedi je suis désolé, j'ai pas d'autres
c'est pas à pas, comment vous dire ?
C'est pas euh il y a il y a il y a il y
a une crise systémique qui va faire
qu'il va avoir des ruptures, des
bouleversements et cetera. Donc moi, la
seule chose que je peux vous conseiller,
c'est d'aller là où au plus près là où
où demain vous aurez le plus de
possibilités de de peser,
c'est à vous de décider et ça c'est les
les gilets jaunes qui ont décidé qui
pardon les porte-paroles, Ludovski et
cetera qui sont quand même des gens très
modérés contrairement à ce que le
gouvernement a essayé de dire qui cette
fois ont dit cette fois c'est à vous de
décider. Nous, ça fait ça fait 15 actes
qu'on se fait mépriser, écraser,
humilié, enfin 17 actes pardon. Euh là
maintenant, on a on n'est plus
responsable de rien. Euh à chacun
décidé, je pense qu'il y aura pas de
violence. Je pense que de toute façon,
la violence qui avait été mise en place
par les gilets jaunes jusqu'ici était
était pas du tout une violence au sens
naturel du terme, enfin au sens commun
du terme. La violence un significant
creux. Un échange peut être violent, un
coût peut être violent. La violence qui
ont mis en place les gilets jaunes a
touché des symboles, a touché des
institutions. Elle elle a pas touché des
individus ou seulement la marge. Elle a
touché des gens qui jouaient une
fonction qui était de s'opposer à un
mouvement social parce que le
gouvernement, c'est aussi de la même
façon que les violences policières
m'intéressent pas. Euh le gouvernement a
décidé de pas répondre politiquement à
cette crise. Donc il a envoyé les
policiers pour étouffer le mouvement.
évidemment qu'ils ne peuvent le faire
que de façon violente. Donc essayer
d'aller chercher si le LBD, si je sais
pas quoi, c'est pas le sujet. Le sujet
c'est comment est-ce que pourquoi est-ce
qu'il y a pas de capacité à à avoir un
dialogue, une didactique politique à ces
sujets. Et ben moi je pense que ce
bouquin donne la réponse à à cette
question et que dès lors
violence d'un côté, violence de l'autre,
c'est que le le fruit en fait de cette
de cette aporie et pas du tout la
question qu'il faut traiter. Alors,
est-ce que un FWI qui rentre dans un
ministère euh pour symboliquement dire
euh c'est cet hôtel particulier qui est
censé porter la parole euh des Français
qui a été construit ou investi parce que
on a fait une révolution, la révolution
française de laquelle on retirait à des
aristocrates le pouvoir pour le rendre
au peuple. Est-ce que vous vous avez le
droit de devenir aristocrate à travers
ces outils que nous avons financé, que
nous avons créé, que nous avons arraché
avec notre sang, avec nos larmes, avec
notre sueur ? Est-ce que est-ce Est-ce
que vous avez le droit d'utiliser ce ces
outils là pour nous écraser, nous
humilier, nous violenter et cetera
physiquement, verbalement et cetera ?
Non. Donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? On
rentre, on défonce la porte pour montrer
symboliquement que cet espace est à nous
aussi. Pas à nous ceux qui défonçent la
porte. C'est pour ça qu'ils sont pas
appropriés d'espace. Juste pour dire
nous au peuple français. Et donc pour
dire à Benjamin Rivau, c'est suffi. Vous
êtes un élu du vous êtes censé
représenter le peuple. Vous êtes pas
censé représenter vos intérêts. Est-ce
que c'est violent ou est-ce que c'était
tout ce qu'avait fait Benjamin Griv les
mois précédents qui était violent ?
Tu me fais penser à une histoire mais je
sais pas si
par contre c'est évident que tout ce qui
est violence gratuite, attaquer des
individus, terrorisme et cetera, ça n'a
aucun sens. Moi ma ma thèse, mon
doctorat, mon pseudo faux doctorat qui
est en ligne hein à tout le monde, c'est
sur la violence de masse. C'est donc
toutes mes études, c'est la réflexion du
rapport à la violence, c'est comment
est-ce qu'on est on en arrive à
commettre des violences de masse et
comment l'éviter. Et c'est pour ça quand
quand c'était vu en juillet 2017, je
pense pour le premier entretien qu'on
avait fait, je
vous avez été visionnaire. Bah, j'étais
en capacité de de l'être parce que c'est
mon sujet d'étude. C'estàd que j'ai
travaillé, j'ai j'ai lu ce qu'il y avait
à lire sur le sujet de façon
systématique, super étendu. J'en ai fait
mon objet de recherche. Donc évidemment,
à un moment, je suis capable de
comprendre euh les dialectiques qui se
mettent en place, les les et euh et donc
c'est évidemment dans l'objectif de de
résoudre les conflits politiques qui qui
provoquent cette violence là. C'est mais
pour moi la violence encore une fois
c'est les 15000 morts qui chaque année
meurent dans générale et l'indifférence
c'est double violence des 15000 morts et
l'indifférence par rapport à ces 15000
morts cette violence là je la mets pas
en équivalence avec celle des gilets
jaunes celle des gilets jaunes est
complètement insignifiante complètement
signifiante en rapport à cette violence
systémique. Et si on peut arriver à une
société où on réduit cette violence là
bah évidemment
c'est ce que recherche les gilets jaunes
et ce que ce qu'on recherche tous je
pense.
Autre question cette case dont vous
parlez est-ce un mal français ? C'est un
c'est très particulier. Ouais. C'est que
le système de la 5e République et de du
capitalisme d'État euh français qui
s'est mis en place dans l'aprègerre pour
reconstruire le pays a autorisé toutes
ces dérives. Je vous parlais en fait de
la dérive Jean-Luc Lagard, Arnaud
Lagarder. Cet effondrement c'estàd qu'on
a un système qui quelque part on peut
être en opposition idéologique avec mais
peut avoir ses vertus et ses défauts.
C'est le moment où on confie à des
capitaines d'industrie des biens communs
pour essayer d'en d'en faire quelque
chose qui nous permettront à terme de
créer Airbus. Finalement, on peut se
dire bah dans tout ça, il y a quand même
eu quelque chose qui nous a permis de de
rayonner et qui après va s'effondrer
parce que par compromission, copinage,
héritage tout simplement, on va mettre
ces outils là entre des mains de
personnes qui vont penser qu'à eux et
qui ne vont avoir aucune vision, aucun
talent, aucune compétence et on va avoir
un effondrement comme ça particulier.
Donc oui, du coup, évidemment, le
système politico-économique français
favorise énormément ça. Et bon, j'en ai
parlé là, c'est serait trop loin à
expliquer, mais l'imbation
du système de enfin de l'Union
européenne, des politiques de l'Union
européenne euh
du système de prédation en fait que met
en place la France pour assurer ses
richesses à travers la multinationale à
l'étranger en assurant en fait à ces
multinationale dans le marché intérieur
des marchés captifs notamment avec Vinc
les autoroutes par exemple qui va
permettre à Vinc de marger avoir des
marges garanties dans l'espace
intérieur. logique quelque part pour le
système parce que ça va c'est censé
permettre au au à cette multinationale
d'aller capter des marchés à l'étranger
en faisant des offres plus basses que
celles de leurs concurrents parce
qu'elles peuvent elles peuvent compenser
avec le marché intérieur ce qui infini
théoriquement lui permet après de
répatrier les bénéfices qu'elle aura
arraché mais voyez bien que dans
l'ensemble en fait tout le monde y perd
la population française parce qu'elle
perd une partie de son pouvoir d'achat
parce que qui est-ce qui récupère les
fruits infin de cette politique c'est
ceux qui ont des actions. Donc c'est la
la les plus favorisés déjà. Donc vous
accroissez les inégalités systémiquement
en mettant en place ce système.
Évidemment vous comportez de façon
prédatrice par rapport au pays étrangers
où vous captez ses marchés au détriment
de la libre concurrence et cetera. Et
donc vous créez un système qui infé ne
peut qu'amener à la rupture parce qu'il
ne peut qu'amener qu'à une un
accroissement des inégalités du pillage
qui va provoquer des révoltes des
révolutions et cetera. Donc il est très
cohérent dans l'esprit des de ces
personnes-là parce qu'elles sont des des
dirigeants actuels et de 30 dernières
années parce que c'est des personnes qui
ont une courte vue, qui ne pense qu'à
des intérêts de de court terme et qui
ont aucun rapport éthique aux politiques
en pensant que l'éthique en fait est une
question secondaire alors que l'éthique
est au fondement du faire société. Si
vous créez une société sans éthique,
c'est vous cré une société sans rapport
à l'autre. Donc évidemment qu'un moment
elle s'effondre et mais donc voilà à
court terme ça tient à long terme ça
s'effondre.
J'envoie une petite salve une petite
salve.
Quelles sont vos relations avec cette
caste maintenant ? Vous continuez à la
croiser sur les plateaux télé point
d'interrogation.
Vous avez rencontré vous avez rencontré
des soutiens dans la caste point
d'interrogation.
Et pourquoi la police protège encore
cette caste ?
Donc la police, on va on va le prendre.
La police, on l'a expliqué hein, parce
qu'il y a eu très clairement une
politique clientelliste mise en place
par le par le pouvoir pour essayer de la
désolidariser de des personnes qui les
ressemblaient.
Faut quand même rappeler ça. Euh et
c'est c'est probablement gagné et c'est
possible que gilets jaunes s'étouffent
et soit écrasé du fait de cette
désolidarisation qui est intervenue.
Euh la question des sur les plateaux
télé pareil, on dit le fascisme est dans
la rue et cetera. Le fascisme il est sur
les plateaux télés. Ce que vous croisez
dans les croisez sur un plateau télé,
que ce soit avant, pendant ou après,
systématiquement vous allez avoir un
représentant du Rassemblement national.
Rassemblement national qui n'a plus
qu'un objectif, c'est de s'imposer comme
le parti de l'ordre. D'où l'appel de
Marine Le Pen au respect des
institutions de la 5e République après
cette revue offert par Martin Bougier à
un 20h. Je pense que c'était le premier
20h après l'acte 3, peut-être acte 4 ou
acte mais je pense c'était acte 3.
Regard caméra quand même. C'était
magnifique pendant pendant 2 minutes
dans une adresse à Macron qui était en
fait une adresse au français qui et
qu'elle donne des gages y compris par
exemple quand il y a eu la polémique sur
l'augmentation des actes antisémites. le
Rassemblé national qui s'est fondé sur
son antisémitisme en partie qui quand
même devient le premier pourfondeur en
apparence de l'antisémitisme en disant
"Ah, c'est le fait des des gauchistes et
des et des islamistes, nous nous sommes
les premiers protecteurs de tout ça en
fait c'est des signaux envoyés afin de
s'imposer en fait comme une alternative
crédible pour l'élite parisienne au
service à à Macron." C'est que s'il y
avait fondrement de système euh Marine
Le Pen vise à s'imposer comme
l'alternative parfaite. Et donc c'est
pour ça aussi que sur l'euro sur
l'Europe en fait il n'y a plus de ligne
claire.
C'estàd que vous essayez vraiment et
elle joue en fait parce qu'elle veut en
fait avoir le pouvoir on a l'impression
qu'elle s'oppose au système obtenir le
pouvoir comme ça pour immédiatement
après se mettre au service de ces
personnesl parce qu'elle a bien compris
qu'elle avait besoin de elle avait
besoin de de donner des gages pour pour
y accéder factuellement. Donc on est sur
une dialectique que Macron a a cru euh
parce qu'encore une fois la courte vue
gagnable enfin advitam et ternam qui est
de dire euh c'est soit moi ou le chaos
soit moi ou Le Pen. Et donc du coup Le
Pen a compris le truc et a dit bah j'ai
incarné l'ordre j'ai incarné le surordre
de façon à justement dire bah c'est soit
Macron lâche un lit soit moi. elle
renverse en fait le et je pense que Le
Pen est plus intelligente politiquement
que Macron contrairement à ce qu'il
pense et que du coup Infiné en fait si à
système constant ce sera elle qui
gagnera et pas en 2027 ou 2032 mais en
2022 et donc c'est là aussi où cet appel
au renversement symbolique ou réel sous
quelque forme que ce soit m'apparaît
essentiel, c'est parce qu'on est en
train de préparer en fait le glissement
vers une normalisation
de ce fascisme en fait qui est déjà en
partie au pouvoir parce que il y a quand
même dans la politique menée aujourd'hui
par Macron une grande partie
d'insparition autoritaires qui a des
relans. Quand il dit ceux qui ne sont
rien, c'est une essentialisation d'une
partie de la population. C'est un
discours fascisant et par nature
fasciste d'ailleurs. Est-ce que
l'ensemble de la politique est fasciste
? Pas du tout. Est-ce qu'on est dans un
régime fasciste ? Pas encore. Encore une
fois, 9000 arrestations arbitraires,
3000 blessés et cetera. Vous voyez très
bien que c'est des tendances lourdes qui
dans n'importe quel autre régime, dans
n'importe quel autre pays dans le monde
aur été considéré comme l'expression
d'un excès autoritaire voire dictatorial
ahurissant. En France, on est incapable
malgré les condamnations de l'ONU.
On voit bien aussi la puissance de
d'autorisation là-dessus. C'est condus
de la haute commissaire au droit de
l'homme ont été relayés. Mais est-ce
qu'elles ont fait des unes ? Est-ce
qu'elles ont indigné
dans le commentaire ? Mais je veux dire,
il y a eu des articles factuels pour les
reprendre. Est-ce qu'ils ont eu l'impact
social ? Est-ce qu'on leur a donné
l'impact social qu'il qu'il fallait leur
donner ? Non. Donc du coup ça permet aux
journalistes de se réfugier des dis mais
non on a fait un travail, on en a parlé.
Mais comment est-ce que vous en avez
parlé ? Et à un moment, si on si on
prétend à cette factualité en
permanence, bah on se retrouve à devenir
l'avocat du diable sans aucune sans
aucune limite. Donc donc voilà, les
plateaux télé, c'est et pour répondre à
c question, la caste,
il y aura toujours des personnes qui
chercheront à me récupérer et et des
personnes qui seront prêtes à trahir ou
ou abandonner pour conserver leur
position sociale. Donc oui et
la question c'est c'est quoi en faire en
fait ? Quoi faire de ces qu'elle soit
bonne ou mauvaise volonté ? Quoi faire
pour amener ces gens-là en effet se
désolidariser à reconstruire quelque
chose de de plus sain y compris pour
ensuite s'en débarrassé ? Euh
voilà.
Dernière question parce qu'on arrive à
la fin. C'est pas une question c'est
laisser un conseil pour les jeunes
génération
quelque chose d'impérissable. Une
bouteille à la mer.
J'en avais déjà donné un la dernière
fois, donc je sais pas si euh si euh
si je pourrais euh trouver une nouvelle
en fait
de ma position en plus une nouvelle
possibilité de de recommander quoi que
ce soit. Moi, je pense qu'il y a une
Non, j'ai pas de conseil à donner cette
fois. J'ai je pense que j'ai j'ai fait
ce que j'avais à faire. J'ai joué mon
rôle. Je pense qu'il y a une nouvelle
phase dans ma vie qui s'ouvre maintenant
et c'est à chacun de de se déterminer à
partir de de ce que j'ai pu transmettre
euh avec ce dernier geste en fait qui
est ce livre qui a pour envie est la fin
d'un la fin d'un parcours et et à chacun
maintenant de de trouver sa voix quoi à
partir de ce que moi ma modeste mesure
j'ai pu j'ai pu contribuer à former
Branco. Merci
merci à vous.
[Musique]